ORDER AND GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE IN RESPONSE THE
COVERED NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IN HERE TO A
STRICT SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES.
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO TO WHICH
TESTIFIED TODAY. INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER. AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN. AND I WILL ALSO
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR I'LL REPEAT THAT.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND WE HAVE
AN ACCESS CODE WHICH IS. SEVEN
FOUR ZERO SEVEN FOUR EIGHT NINE
AND AGAIN THE ACCESS CODE IS.
SEVEN FOUR ZERO SEVEN FOUR
EIGHT NINE FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE TELECOM
SYSTEM WORKS YOU MAY REFER TO
THE SENATE. N. OR THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITES. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE AND THEN ZERO. FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A LITTLE BIT
OF A WEIGHT SO IT'S IMPORTANT
TO BE PATIENT ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER HE WILL WAIT
IN A QUEUE. FOR THE MODERATOR
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME YOU WILL BE I'M MUTED AND
HE WILL NOW BE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ALL THAT
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
YOUR DEVICE THAT YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY AGAIN
WHEN YOU START TO SPEAK MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING US
ON. IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM
YOU AND WE WANT TO DO THAT
UNENCUMBERED AND WE ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE. I'LL
TRY MY BEST TO MAINTAIN THE
DECORUM DURING THIS HEARING AS
CUSTOMARY AND INDIVIDUALS WHO
MAY CHOOSE TO BE DISRUPTIVE-
WOULD BE REMOVED OBVIOUSLY OR
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE IS
OR HOW THE COMMUNICATIONS. UNIT
SO PLEASE EVERYBODY. PRACTICE
GOOD DECORUM IT'S ALSO A GOOD
TIME TO REMIND EVERYONE.
PROVIDING TESTIMONY. THIS IS A
FISCAL COMMITTEE. WE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO THE FISCAL ASPECTS
OF THE BILL WHEN YOU'RE
TESTIFYING AND PLEASE REFRAIN.
FROM REPEATING THE POLICY
ARGUMENTS YOU MAY HAVE MADE
BEFORE WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE RE
LITIGATING THE MERITS. OF THIS
PROPOSAL BASED ON THIS POLICY
WE'RE GOING TO BE FOCUSED ON
THE FISCAL IMPLICATIONS OF THE
BILLS BEFORE US. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
TO CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS. IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES
WILL TRY TO BE RESPECTFUL OF
YOU AND PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL.
OF OUR SYSTEM AND OUR PERSONAL.
WE HAVE SEVENTY EIGHT BILLS
TODAY ON OUR AGENDA THREE ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR TO PASS MOTION.
THE REMAINING BILLS ARE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATES. I BELIEVE
ALL OF THE AUTHORS HAVE WAVE
PRESENTATION IS THAT CORRECT
MARC. THE ALL THE AUTHORS OF
WAVE PRESENTATION ON THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATES. WE WILL
PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
PUBLIC TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY ON
EACH MEASURE AS THEY COME UP.
BEFORE WE HEAR YOUR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILL WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND ESTABLISH
A QUORUM SO IF YOU WOULD CALL
THE ROLL. PORTANTINO I'M HERE
UNTIL HERE BATES BATES HERE
BRADFORD BRADFORD PRESIDENT
HILL HERE KILL HERE JONES. YOUR
LEYVA HERE LEYVA HERE. IN MY
COUNTY. WE HAVE SIX MEMBERS OF
A QUORUM WE HAVE A QUORUM-
WE'RE GONNA BE MOVING THROUGH
THE AGENDA IN FILE ORDER BUT
ALL BILLS AUTHORED BY AN
INDIVIDUAL MEMBER WILL BE TAKEN
UP BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT AUTHOR WE HAVE INCLUDED A
COPY OF OUR BILL BY BILL AGENDA
ON THE FRONT PAGE OF THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE WHICH IS W.
W. W. S. A. P. R. DOT SENATE
DOT CA DOT GOV W. W. W. DOT S.
A. P. R. DOT SENATE. DOT CA DOT
GOV IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
WANTS TO FOLLOW UP TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF THE HEARING
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS
INCLUDING PROTOCOLS. WE MAIN
HEADS TO THE TIME LIMIT TIME
INSTITUTE A TIME LIMIT. AS
THINGS PROGRESS AGAIN IF EACH
SIDE WILL BE PERMITTED AN EQUAL
AMOUNT OF TIME REGARDLESS. OF
WHAT I DO BEYOND THAT. THE KEY
SPEAKERS- FALL OTHERS WISHING
TO TESTIFY WILL LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION ON
THE MEASURES. AND WE'RE GONNA
REALLY HOLD EVERYBODY TO THEIR
ME TO USE AND AFFILIATIONS. SO
OUR FIRST AUTHOR IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW. HE IS HERE- THE
FIRST ITEM BEFORE US IS AB
EIGHT NINETY SIX WHICH WAS
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
NINE TEN BY THE BILL MEETS THE
CRITERIA FOR REFERRAL TO
SUSPENSE FILE WILL TWENTY NINE
TEN. ONLY PROVIDES US LIMITED
OPTIONS WE COULD HOLD THE BILL
RETURN THE BILL HAS APPROVED BY
THE COMMITTEE TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SO WE ARE HEARING THE
BILL AND THOSE ARE TWO OPTIONS
AND- MR LOW PLEASE TELL US
ABOUT AB EIGHT NINETY SIX AND
AGAIN WE'RE TRYING TO CAN.
CONTENT THEMSELVES TO THE
FISCAL IMPACTS OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR AND I'VE
MEMBERS THIS IS IT AB EIGHT
NINETY SIX WHICH- EXPAND VISION
SERVICES TO THOSE IN NEED
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THIS
ALSO HAS SUPPORT FROM THE BOARD
OF OPTOMETRY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE-
THEO BAJA TACOS. WITH VISION TO
LEARN. ON THE COASTLINE IS YOUR
PRIMARY SPORT WITNESS FOR A. B.
NINETY SIX EIGHT NINETY SIX
PLEASE. MISTER POLISH. MR
POSITIVE TESTIMONY. TO TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. ON BEHALF OF THE
SPONSORS VERSION TO LEARN
REGIONAL ARE NOT PROVIDED
VISION SERVICES AND GLASSES
FREE OF CHARGE TO OVER ONE
HUNDRED NINETY SIX THOUSAND
DISADVANTAGED CALIFORNIA
STUDENT. INCLUDING THOSE IN THE
PASADENA IN COMPTON SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. THE BILL CLEARS A
REGULATORY TECHNICALITY THAT
WILL BRING US AND NONPROFITS
LIKE US INTO FULL COMPLIANCE
WITH THE LAW. THIS WILL ALLOW
US TO DRAW DOWN PRIVATE DOLLARS
BETTER ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE
GREATER THAN THE ESTIMATED COST
OF THIS BILL TO ALLOW US TO
EXPAND OUR SERVICES. THROUGHOUT
THE GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND THANK MR LOW PRINCE
LEADERSHIP. IN THIS AREA THANK
YOU. OUR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN ROOM.
FORTY TWO THREE. NOBODY RUN UP
TO THE MICROPHONE. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SEEING NO ONE RUN UP TO
THE MICROPHONE THERE WE HAVE
OUR SENATE IT STAFF. IT IS
LET'S GO TO. MOM MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
MARTELLUS SYSTEM. SIR ANYBODY
ONLINE THAT WANTS TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT NINE SIX.
AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE IN Q. X.
LINE ONE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MARTHA CARRERA
REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES.
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT-
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR WE ARE
GOING TO GO TO ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION IS OR ANYBODY IN
THIS ROOM IS OPPOSED. NINE IS
THERE ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY.
SIR ANYONE ONLINE IN OPPOSITION.
ONCE AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE ONLINE. ALL RIGHT THEN
LET'S DOUBLE CHECK ONE MORE
TIME SUPPORTER OPPOSITION ON
THIS BILL. HEARING NOBODY
ONLINE ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO SEE IF THERE'S A FILE ON
THIS BILL. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JULIE UNDER
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
I DON'T HAVE A FILE ON THE
STATURE. ALL RIGHT WE DON'T
HAVE A FILE WE'RE GONNA BRING
THIS BACK TO DISCUSSION TO THE
MEMBERS TO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR MR LOW.
OF THE BILL I HAVE A MOTION ON
THE BILL. WHICH BRADFORD AS A
QUESTION JUST QUICK QUESTION.
HOW DOES A ORGANIZATION.
QUALIFY FOR THOSE FUNDS-
RECEIVE THOSE FUNDS. MAYBE IF I
MY TO THE CHAIR TASK A DEAL.
VISION TO LEARN AS THEY ARE THE
ONES THAT IMPLEMENTED THE ROLE
THAT WE HAVE IS ON THE
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE ENTITY IS
COMPLIANT INTO PERHAPS THE
CHAIR THE ANTIQUE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO ANSWER THAT. SENATE RECORD.
BY THE ONLINE. MISTER YES THE
AUDIENCE ARE OKAY THEO KEEP
GOING. MISTER CHAIRMAN- AN
ENTITY WOULD QUALIFY. FOR THIS
BILL IF THEY WERE A NONPROFIT
PROVIDED VISION CARE SIR. AND
WERE IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
REST OF THE CONTENTS OF THE
BILL AS WELL AS THE BUSINESS A
OPTOMETRY REGULATIONS. OKAY ALL
RIGHT ONLY REASON BECAUSE I HAD
A- SERVICE ON ROPERTY PROVIDE
DIE GLASSES INTO FIRST AND MY
IN A ASKED ABOUT THE TOUGHEST.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SEEN
NEITHER. BEST LOW JULY TO CLOSE
THIS FOR S. FOR. ARE WE HAVE A
SHORT SO CLOSE ANIMO BY MY
LEYVA REMEMBER THE MOTION IS TO
RETURN THE MEMBER MEASURE TO
THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
CONSIDERATION. MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MEASURE IS ASSEMBLY BILL A
NINETY SIX ON THE MOTION IS
THAT THE MEASURE BE ADOPTED
I'LL BE RETURNED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR FOR CONSIDERATION SENATOR
PORTANTINO HI. PORTANTINO HI
BATES RIGHT BATES FIVE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL AYE JONES. JONES ARE LEYVA
BY LEYVA HI MY COUNTY. SIX OF
THE REST VOTES WILL LEAVE IT ON
CALL FOR MISTER WHITE COW SKI
YOUR BILL WILL GO TO THE SENATE
FLOOR THANK YOU MR LOW. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO MR MCCARTY
SPILLS SWITCHER ALL SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES. AND HERE'S WAY
PRESENTATION SO THE NEXT ITEM
FROM OUR AGENDA IS AB ONE
TWENTY THREE. WHICH IS A SPEND
SCANNERS AS I MENTIONED AND
PRESENTATION WAS WARY OF THEIRS
OR ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE TWENTY THREE. SEEING NO
RUSH TO THE MICROPHONE. TWENTY
ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY. IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE TWENTY THREE.
SEEING NO RUSH TO THE
MICROPHONE THERE. MISTER
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ONLINE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB ONE TWENTY THREE. ONCE
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN ZERO.
WE HAVE NO ONE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE TO
OPPOSITION IS OR ANYONE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE OPPOSED TO
AB ONE TWENTY THREE SAYING NO
ONE HERE HOW BOUT WE MOVED TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SURE ANYONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. THERE'S
NOBODY THERE. IS THERE ANYONE
ONLINE WHO WOULD LIKE TO OPPOSE
AB ONE TWENTY THREE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVEN'T
ARE KNOWN IN Q. ALL RIGHT
THERE'S NO SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ONLINE SO- WE WILL
MOVE- FACT TO THIS ROOM ON AB
ONE TWENTY THREE. DO ANY
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB ONE TWENTY
THREE IS MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE MISTER Y. CASKEY IS HERE-
HELLO I'M SORRY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I FORGOT CHIU JOINING.
IS THERE FILE IN AB ONE TWENTY
THREE. YES WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THIS BILL THIS TIME
THAT WOULD NOTE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
ESTIMATES TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE COSTS TO STATE SUBSIDIZED
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS OF
NINETEEN MILLION TO TWENTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUSPEND
FAMILY FEAST FOR FAMILIES-
BETTER ENROLLED IN STATE
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE PROGRAMS
BUT RECEIVE ONLY DISTANCE
LEARNING SERVICES. WE WOULD
KNOW THAT- THIS BILL COULD
CREATE SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND
COST PRESSURES TO EXPAND ACCESS
TO STATE CHILD CARE SUBSIDIES.
TO THE EXTENT THAT DIRECT
CERTIFICATION TO MEDI CAL AND
CALFRESH INCREASES THE DEMAND
FOR SUBSIDIES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MY BAD MISTER WHITE HOUSE
HE'S DISTRACTED ME I'M BLAMING
IT ON YOU SO HEARING THAT AND
SEEING NO OBJECTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB ONE TWENTY THREE
IS MOVE TO SUSPENSE. I'M GONNA
OPEN THE ROLE ON A V. EIGHT
NINETY SIX MISTER LOWE SAYS MR
WHITE HOUSE GEARS HERE. MISTER
SECTOR IF YOU COULD CALL. THE
ROLE ON THE ABSENT MEMBER ON AB
EIGHT NINETY SIX AB EIGHT
NINETY SIX EIGHT NINETY SIX THE
MOTION IS THAT THE MEASURE BE
RETURNED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
FOR CONSIDERATION BY CASKEY HI
MAKOWSKI BY. BILL HAS SEVEN OF
SEVEN WAS OUT SEVEN TO ZERO
MISTER Y. CASKEY WE HAVE FOR
YOU HERE FOR A WHILE OR USE
RUNNING BACK AND FORTH. BECAUSE
WE'RE GONNA BE DOING SUSPENSE.
ONLY FOR A LONG TIME SO NOT TO
OUR NEXT TWO PASSES IT FOR A
WHILE SO. JUST LETTING YOU KNOW
OKAY. MOVING ON TO OUR THIRD
BILL. AB SIX FORTY SIX BY
MISTER MCCARTY ALSO SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WITH WAY
PRESENTATION. FOR ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
IN FAVOR OF AB SIX FORTY SIX
SEEN NOBODY HEARS OR ANYBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. IN FAVOR OF
AB SIX FORTY SIX. SEEING NO ONE
IN THE ROOM THE SIX FOOT IN A
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SIR ANYONE
ONLINE IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
FORTY SIX MISTER MODERATOR. GOT
ONE MORE BILL JUDITH AND PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT ONCE
AGAIN ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE
KNOWING QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM. OPPOSED TO AB SIX
FORTY SIX SEEING NO ONE HERE
BUT MISTER MCKINLEY IN HIS SEAT
FORGOT A ROOM TWENTY FORTY. IS
THERE ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. OPPOSED AB SIX FORTY SIX.
NO ONE IS THERE IS THERE ANYONE
ONLINE MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP. OUR PHONE LINE FOR
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF. A. B.
SIX FORTY SIX. OKAY PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO IF YOU'D
LIKE TO OPPOSE. ONCE. AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. SO
HAVING NO SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION ONLINE FOR SIX FORTY
SIX WE WILL GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO FILE
THANK YOU KNOW FILE ALL RIGHT
ANY MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIX FORTY SIX.
WE'LL GO TO SUSPEND. MOVING TO
AB THREE TWO TWO SIX ALSO BY MR
MCCARTY. WHO WAS WAY
PRESENTATION IS THERE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT IN THIS ROOM FOR AB
THREE TWO TWO SIX. SEEING NONE
IS THERE ANYONE IN TWENTY
FORTY. IN SUPPORT. SAYING NO
ONE THERE MISTER MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ONLINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE TWO TWO TWO SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT. ONCE
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION THERE'S
NO ONE IN THIS ROOM AND OPPOSED
TO FORTY TWO OF THREE IS
RUNNING ONE IN FROM TWENTY
FORTY OPPOSED. TO THIRTY TWO
TWENTY SIX NINE STRANRAER IS
ANYBODY ONLINE WHO'S OPPOSED AB.
THIRTY TWO TWENTY SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION ONCE AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE IN Q. ALL RIGHTS IS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE OF
FILE. THANK YOU CHAIR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
ESTIMATES THERE WILL BE NO
IMMEDIATE COST TO THE
DEPARTMENT FROM THE BILL OF ANY
FUTURE COSTS WOULD BE NEEDED
ONCE FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDING
IS. SECURED AND THE PROJECT IS
DEVELOPED. THE DEPARTMENT
ESTIMATES THE CURRENT STATE
SHARE THIS PROJECT IS
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION DOLLARS. WHICH WOULD BE
FUNDEDEITHER THROUGH THE
GENERAL FUND OR FUTURE BOND
FUNDS. LASTLY THIS BILL MAY
CREATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE BECAUSE IT TRANSFERS
COMPLETE OR PARTIAL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS
PROGRAM. OF WHICH THE STATE
CURRENTLY HAS COMPLETE OR
PARTIAL FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY- TO A LOCAL
AGENCY. RIGHT C. ANY QUESTIONS
SEEM NO HANDS GO UP. WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY
SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AND FOR
THE RECORD- AB ONE TWENTY THREE
WAS ON EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION AB SIX FORTY SIX. WAS
ELECTIONS VOTER ELIGIBILITY AND
AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY SIX WAS ON
FLOOD PROTECTION. FOR THE WEST
SACRAMENTO AREA AND SO. THEY
HAVE ALL GONE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO OUR NEXT AUTHOR.
WHICH IS MISS FRIEDMAN'S AB TWO
SEVEN SIX AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION ON THE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. IS AND THIS BILL IS
ON PERSONAL INCOME TAXES
QUALIFIED EMPLOYEE PLAN LOANS
RELATED TO THE CARE ACT. TWENTY
ONE IN. THIS ROOM SEEING NONE
IS THERE ANYBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY WISHING TO SPEAK ON TO
SEVENTY SIX SEEING NONE MISTER
MODERATORS ANYBODY ONLINE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK ON A BEACH
TWO. SIX ONCE AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ONE ZERO.
THERE'S NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHT
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
HERE THERE'S NO ONE IS THERE
ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED
TO AB TWO SEVEN SIX. SIR ANYONE
ONLINE MISTER MODERATOR OPPOSED
AB TWO SEVEN SIX. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE ONCE AGAIN ONE ZERO. AND
WE HAVE NOBODY IN Q. IN KNOWN
IN Q. OPPOSED OR SUPPORT OF TWO
SEVEN SIX IS THERE A FILE FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YES
THAT THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
ESTIMATES GENERAL FUND REVENUE
LOSSES OF TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION OLLARS IN. TWENTY
TWENTY. AND TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE I WOULD
NOTE THAT THESE REVENUE LOSSES
WERE NOT INCLUDED AS PART OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT.
GREAT THANK YOU- SEEING NO
QUESTIONS BY ANYONE WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWO SEVEN SIX. GO
TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RADIUS HAS A. B. SIX
EIGHTY FIVE WHICH IS
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY CODE
NINETEEN EXPOSURE NOTIFICATIONS
SHE SAID PRESENTATION IS BEEN
WAIVED AND WE WILL GO TO
TESTIMONY IN THIS ROOM IS OR
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
EIGHTY FIVE SEEING NO ONE HEARS
ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NO ONE THERE'S ANYONE
ONLINE MISTER MODERATOR. WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIX EIGHTY FIVE. THEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU WISH
TO SHOW SUPPORT ONCE AGAIN ONE
ZERO. AND THERE'S NOBODY IN Q.
NO ONE QUEUED UP FOR SUPPORT
HOW ABOUT WE GO TO THIS ROOM
FOR OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE
TWENTY FORTY. I SEE NO ONE
MISTER MODERATORS ANYONE QUEUED
UP IN OPPOSITION. OF AB SIX
EIGHTY FIVE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
DO WISH TO OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IT'S ONE
NINE ZERO AND WE DO HAVE ONE
PERSON THAT'S QUEUED UP ONE
MOMENT WHEN THEY GET THEIR LINE
NUMBER. AND WE'RE GOING TO LINE
ONE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE ONE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS SUSAN BOB NAYLOR
REPRESENTING SIX BEDS I THINK
IT'S AN ASSOCIATION OF ASSISTED
LIVING HOMES AND WE WERE
OPPOSED AB SIXTY FIVE BECAUSE
WE ALREADY REPORT EXTENSIVELY
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE SUPPOSED. TO SIX
EIGHTY FIVE. WE HAVE NO FRTHER
IN Q ALL RIGHT THIS DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE HAVE A FILE. THANK
YOU QALISYA REPORTS THAT THE
FISCAL IMPACT OF THIS BILL IS
UNCERTAIN AND WOULD BE
DEPENDENT UPON THE DYNAMICS OF
THE PANDEMIC IF PRESENT
CONDITIONS CONTINUE AN
ESTIMATED TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND I
WOULD BE NEEDED FOR IT COSTS
ACCRETION OF AN ONLINE PORTAL.
ESTIMATION OF REPORTS AND
PROMULGATION OF REGULATIONS ON
GOING COSTS ARE ESTIMATED TO
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND.
AND FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH THE ESTIMATE
GENERAL FUND COSTS FOR
MINISTRATION OF NINE HUNDRED
SIXTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
ONE POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER. FINALLY
THE DEPARTMENT INSURANCE
ESTIMATES INSURANCE FUND COST
OF TWO HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. FOUR HUNDRED FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THEREAFTER.
THANK YOU. ANYBODY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS SIGNAL HANDS GO UP.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SIX EIGHTY
FIVE. WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON TO AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY SEVEN. ON CONVICTIONS
EXPUNGEMENT FOR- BUT THOSE WHO
ARE ON CAMPUS CRUZ. ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT. TWENTY
ONE FORTY SEVEN. THREE NINE
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY. SEEING
NINE ANYONE QUEUED UP. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU WISH
TO SHOW UPPORT. ONE ZERO. ONE
MOMENT IT DOES LOOK LIKE WE
HAVE ONE PERSON COMING UP. AND
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE LINE ONE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS WHO
NEED CURRENT LAW ON BEHALF OF
THE QUALITY CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. AND ONCE AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
SHOW SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
NOBODY QUEUED UP OPPOSED OR IN
SUPPORT. I'M SURE THAT WAS THE
SUPPORT BACK LET'S GO TO THIS
ROOM FOR OPPOSITION SEEING
NOBODY ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
OPPOSED. EVERYBODY QUEUED UP
ONLINE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVENTIES
PRESS. PARDON ME PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE. ONE ZERO. I DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE IN CUBA. ALL RIGHT KNOWN
QUEUED UP LET'S GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. FILE IN
TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN YES WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
BILL AT THIS TIME BUT WOULD
NOTE THAT- THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
ESTIMATES MINOR NOTES OR WILL
COSTS. THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ESTIMATES ONGOING
ANNUAL GENERAL FUND COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND WE WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT TO THE EXTENT THAT COURT
ORDERS- THAT THE COURT ORDERS
EARLY TERMINATION OF PROBATION
PAROLE. OR SUPERVISED RELEASE
THAT THERE COULD BE SOME COST
SAVINGS TO STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES. GREAT SIGNAL HANDS GO
UP. AB TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN.
GO TO SUSPENSE WITHOUT
OBJECTION MOVING ONTO AB TWENTY
TWO SEVENTY SIX ON CHILDHOOD
LEAD POISONING. IS THERE ANYONE
IN THIS ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SAYING NOT
ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY. SEEING
NONE ANYONE QUEUED UP IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT. ONE ZERO. AND THERE'S
NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHTS ANY
OPPOSITION IN THIS ROOM SCENE
NINE ANY OPPOSITION IN TWENTY
FORTY. SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANYONE QUEUED UP IN OPPOSITION
AB. TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY SIX.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO OPPOSE ONCE AGAIN
ONE ZERO. AND NOBODY IN Q. ALL
RIGHT PARTMINER FINANCE. MISTER
TURNER FOR YES WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT
WOULD RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
A AND IS A DUPLICATIVE EFFORTS
CURRENTLY UNDERWAY AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND DEPARTMENT. OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. I WOULD NOTE
THAT THIS BILL COULD. INCREASE
MEDICAL LOCAL ASSISTANCE COSTS
IN THE LOW TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS APPROXIMATELY HALF OF
WHICH WOULD BE GENERAL FUND. A
RESULTING FROM THE REQUIREMENT
FOR EACH MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
PLAN TO ESTABLISH A BLOOD LEAD
SCREENING MONITORING SYSTEM.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL IS
ESTIMATED TO INCREASE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES STATE OPERATIONS
COSTS. IN THE MID HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS. ALL RIGHT
ANY QUESTIONS FOR MY COLLEAGUE
SEEN NONE. WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SIX WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. MOVING TO MISTER
MOLOT AB SEVEN THIRTEEN. ON
PRIVACY CONSUMER PRIVACY IS
THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM. IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN THIRTEEN.
IS THERE ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. TWENTY ONE ONLINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN THIRTEEN.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT ONCE
AGAIN ONE ZERO. AND THERE'S
NOBODY IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION ON EIGHTY SEVEN
THIRTEEN NO ONE'S HERE FOR
ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
OPPOSED. SEEING NINE IS THERE
ANYONE ONLINE. WHO WOULD LIKE
TO OPPOSE AB SEVEN THIRTEEN.
PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHT TO
PART IN FINANCE. YES WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE DUE TO
THE POTENTIAL FOR INCREASED
GENERAL FUND COSTS THAT ARE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE STATE'S CURRENT
FISCAL PLAN. A JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COST OF THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
THANK YOU VERY QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES SEEING NONE THE
AUTHORS SWAY PRESENTATION AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SEVEN
THIRTEEN WILL GO TO SUSPEND FOR
THE MOVE ON TO AB TWENTY EIGHT
OH NINE ALSO BY MR MULLIN. ON
THE MARCH PRESERVATION ACT- IS
OR ANYONE IN THIS ROOM. SEEING
NINE ANYONE IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
SEEING NONE ANYONE ONLINE. AB
TWENTY PLEASE PRESS EIGHT OH
NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHT SIR
ANY OPPOSITION SEEING NONE IN
THIS ROOM ANY OPPOSITION IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NONE
IS THERE ANYONE CUED UP WHO
WOULD LIKE TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY
EIGHT OH NINE. FOR PLEASE PRESS
ONE MIN ZERO FOR OPPOSITION.
ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE NOBODY IN
Q. ALL RIGHTS- DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. IS THE COMMISSION
INDICATES THAT THE REQUIREMENTS
OUTLINED IN THIS BILL WOULD BE
MINOR AN OBSERVABLE WE KNOW
THAT THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET
ACTED INCLUDED LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS TO IMPLEMENT THE
CHANGES- TO THE ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAM- HOWEVER ONGOING REVIEW
OF THE ENFORCEMENT DECISIONS
MAY REQUIRE ADDITIONAL ONGOING
RESOURCES IF NOT COMPLETED
BEYOND JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY.
TWENTY ONE. SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB TWENTY
NINE NINE WITH A SUSPENSE MOVIE
ON TO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS
WHO IS WAY PRESENTATION EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE. THIRTY
SUPPORT IN THIS ROOM C. NINE
ATTORNEY SUPPORT IN. TWENTY
FORTY SEEING NINE AS ANYONE
QUEUED UP. HAN AB SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE
ZERO IF YOU WANT WOULD LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT. ONE ZERO. AND WE
DO HAVE ONE THAT IS QUEUED UP
IT'S LINE ONE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BOB NAIL REPRESENTING
FEELS SEVEN COMPANY A AN ORANGE
COUNTY BUSINESS STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF. CALIFORNIA YIMBY
AND STRONGLY SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
ANYONE ELSE ONLINE. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT ANY
OPPOSITION SEEING NOT IN THIS
ROOM. ANY OPPOSITION IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEEING NAINA
OPPOSITION ONLINE. AND IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SHOW OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ONE ZERO.
WE DO HAVE ONE IN CUBA
DISAPPEAR MOMENT. WE'LL GO TO
THE LINE ONE THIRTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS HOLLY ALL FORMS I'M
A REGISTERED PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I LIVE IN A CITY
WHERE WE HAVE A LOT OF TO
UNLOCK. AND RELOCK WHAT YOU
WANT FOR THE FOR A LOT BUT THE
WAY YOU. COULD ON THE BILL
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO COUNT FOR
THE RIGHT CATEGORIES AND IT
COULD BE AN ACCOUNTING
NIGHTMARE SO I AM OPPOSED. TO
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS BILL
THAT WOULD KNOW THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES
COST OF ONE HUNDRED FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
IN THE FIRST YEAR AND NINETY
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE
SECOND YEAR TO UPGRADE THE
PROGRAM GUIDELINES TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
OUTREACH. ALL RIGHT SEEING NO
QUESTIONS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SEVEN TWENTY FIVE.
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO. A. B. SEVEN
THIRTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BONTA. ON INCARCERATED.
PREGNANT PERSONS THE NEXT ITEM
THAT HAS BEEN WAIVED OBVIOUSLY
AND IT'S OR ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
IN SUPPORT. C. NINE TWENTY
FOURTEEN. SEEING NONE TWENTY
ONE IN THE QUEUE- AND WISHES TO
SNEAK PEEK IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN THIRTY TWO. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO YOU'D LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHTS
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN THIRTY
TWO THERE'S NOBODY HERE IN THIS
ROOM IS OR ANYONE IN TWENTY
FORTY THERE'S NO ONE THERE AS
OR ANYONE IN THE QUEUE WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB SEVEN THIRTY TWO. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NOBODY IN Q. ALL
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THANK YOU
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON
THIS BILL- BUT WE KNOW THAT THE
BILL WILL LIKELY RESULT IN
UNKNOWN BUT POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT STATE REIMBURSABLE
COSTS TO COUNTY JAILS PROVIDE
THE SERVICES REQUIRED BY THIS
BILL. ADDITIONALLY COUNTIES MAY
REQUEST A SUBVENTION OF STATE
FUNDS. FOR THE REAL LINE JAIL
POPULATION FOR THE PROVISIONS
OF THIS BILL. LASTLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION ESTIMATES THAT
HAS GONE BACK TO THE STORE
WOULD BE MINOR CIRCLE. ALL
RIGHT ANY QUESTIONS ON AB SEVEN
THIRTY TO SING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION. MAYBE SEVEN
THIRTY TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING TO MS BURKE AB EIGHT
FORTY SIX. PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
POLICE OFFICERS. PRESENTATIONS
BEEN WAGERS ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
AND SUPPORT SEEING NINE ANYONE
IN TWENTY FORTY. SEEN NINE.
TWENTY ONE IN THE QUEUE THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK ON AB EIGHT
FORTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONCE AGAIN ONE ZERO. AND
WE HAVE NOBODY IN CUBA ALL
RIGHT ANY OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE IN THIS ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING ON THEIR TWENTY ONE
ONLINE HAVE POSED AB. EIGHT
FORTY SIX. AND TO SHOW
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON
THIS BILL BUT NO THE POST
ESTIMATES A ONE TIME COST OF
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND TO UPDATE
REGULATIONS UP WITH THESE COSTS
MAY BE OBSERVABLE WITHIN
EXISTING RESOURCES.
ADDITIONALLY THE STILL MAKE
GREAT STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE- TO THE EXTENT THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL REQUIRE
A NEW PROGRAM OR HIGHER LEVEL
OF SERVICE TO BE PROVIDED. BY
LOCAL AGENCIES. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU INDIA QUESTIONS FROM
CALLING SEEING NONE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE V. EIGHT FORTY
SIX WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVIE TV FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
ALSO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE
ON INCOME TAX. AND FEDERAL
WORKERS ACT- IS THERE ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM NOBODY'S HERE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN. HOW ABOUT ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. NOBODY'S THERE
HOW ABOUT ONLINE. AND IF YOU
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE THAT'S Q.
UP WITH JUST A MOMENT WHEN WE
GET THERE LINE NUMBER. THEN
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SIR- I
APOLOGIZE I DID NOT GET MY
COMMENT IN TO OPPOSE EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE MY COMMAND
WAS NOT RECOGNIZED I'D LIKE TO
SLIP IT IN NOW MY NAME IS TESS
TAYLOR ON THE PRESIDENT PRO
TEM. OF THE WEST LOOP THE LAKE
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION AND WE
ARE VERY MUCH OPPOSED TO THAT
BILL WHICH IS A SEVERE THREAT
TO NUMBER CITY I THANK YOU NOT
ATTRACTED ENOUGH HOUSING TO
HIT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
ANYONE ELSE ON AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN. PEOPLE LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT ANY
OPPOSITION FOR FIFTEEN SEVEN
SEVEN. SEEING NO ONE HERE AND
ABOUT TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NO
IN THERE HOW BOUT ONLINE. AND
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NOBODY IN Q.
ALL RIGHT BERMAN FINANCE. WE
WOULD KNOW THAT THIS BILL WILL
NOT HAVE ANY BUDGETARY REVENUE
IMPACT AS THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT OF FORECAST DID NOT
ASSUME THAT ANY OF THE PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM LOAN
FORGIVENESS. WOULD BE TAXED.
ANYBODY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
ABOUT AB FIFTEEN SEVEN SEVEN
SING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB FIFTEEN SEVEN
SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. TO
MISS LIMóN AB TEN SEVENTY ONE.
AGRICULTURAL CLIMATE ADAPTATION
TOOLS. EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM.
THERE'S NO SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
HERE HOW ABOUT ROOM TWENTY
FOURTEEN IS ON HIS WAY
PRESENTATION. THERE'S NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY IS OR ANYONE
ONLINE THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. OF AB TEN SEVENTY
ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT ONE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NOBODY IN Q.
ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION OF TEN
SEVENTY ONE THERE'S NOBODY HERE
HAVE A ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
NOBODY THERE. HOW ABOUT- ONLINE
OPPOSITION TO AB TEN SEVENTY
ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO. AND
WE HAVE NOBODY IN CUBA ALL
RIGHT CARMEN FINANCE A. B. TEN
SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS BILL
THAT WOULD GET THAT- THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A CAP OF UP TO TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO FUND THE
PROGRAM. HOWEVER DOESN'T
IDENTIFY A FUNDING SOURCE- SO
THIS CREATES GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURE ADDITIONALLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE
ESTIMATES NEED FOR ONE POSITION
OR TO ABOUT 5% OF THE TWO
MILLION DOLLARS. TO COMPLETE
THE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS OF THE
PROGRAM. RIGHT SIGNAL QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES AB TEN
SEVENTY ONE HELLO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING TO MISTER SALAS A. B.
FOR. I HAVE A LITTLE REMINDER
HERE. SO WE HAVE
TELECONFERENCING INSTRUCTIONS
ON OUR WEBSITE FOR ANYBODY WHO
WANTS TO TWO MEN AND SPEAK.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBERS
ALSO. 844-291-6364 SERVE
ANYBODY WANTS TO PARTICIPATE
YOU DIAL. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE. ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN
FOUR ZERO SEVEN FOUR EIGHT NINE
AND AGAIN FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS YOU CAN GO TO THE
SENATE OR THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITES. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATOR ANNUAL
STYLE ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
YOUR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR THE OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE. THIS CAN BE
A SHORT WAIT- ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER HE WILL THEN
WAIT IN THE QUEUE. FOR THE
MODERATOR CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER
AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE ON
MUTE IT. AND YOU'RE READY TO.
ADDRESSED THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE FOR US TO HEAR YOU.
ACTUALLY HAVE TO TURN OFF THE
DEVICE OR MUTE THE DEVICE. THAT
YOU'RE LISTENING TO US ON. SO
WHEN YOU GIVE YOUR TESTIMONY.
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
US OR LISTENING TO SO THAT'S
HOW YOU TOO CAN PARTICIPATE IN
THIS. SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE PROCESS. FOR MOVING
TO AB TWELVE NINETY NINE BY
MISTER SALAS. ON PEACE
OFFICERS- HE'S WAY PRESENTATION
TWENTY ONE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
TWELVE NINETY NINE SEEING NONE
IS OR ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANYWAY
ONLINE CUED UP TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE NINETY
NINE. AND IF YOU LIKE TO QUEUE
UP FOR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE ZERO. WE DO
HAVE ONE PERSON IN Q. IT'S LINE
ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. VOTE ONE
MOMENT HERE. ONE ONE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT SIR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE NINETY
NINE ANYBODY HERE KNOW ANYBODY
IN TWELVE FORTY ACTUALLY TWENTY
FORTY. ANYBODY ONLINE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE NINETY
NINE. ONCE AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO TO OPPOSE ONE
ZERO. FINALLY HAVE NOBODY IN Q.
ALL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU WE DON'T
HAVE THIS ISSUE ON THIS BILL
BUT WE KNOW THAT THIS BILL MAY
IMPOSE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE REQUIRING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
INVESTIGATE HE SUFFERED
MISCONDUCT AND REPORT THE
FINDINGS TO POST WHICH MAY
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT ANNUAL
COST TO THE GENERAL FUND.
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS AND RECREATION ESTIMATES
COST OF APPROXIMATELY FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND. FOR THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL. LASTLY
IS CURRENTLY DRAFTED OF. THIS
BILL ME PERTAIN TO NON
COMMISSION CERTIFIED ENTITIES
WHICH WOULD INCLUDE THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. AND IF SO WE
ESTIMATE THE COST TO THE
DEPARTMENT WILL BE IN THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SEE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES A. B. TWELVE NINETY
NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION. MOVED TO AB
NINETEEN OH SIX ALSO BY MR
SALAS ON PREGNANT CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS DUTY ASSIGNMENT
POLICIES HERE'S WAY
PRESENTATION ON ALL OF HIS
BILLS AND I SEE NO ONE IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AS OR ANYONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SINGLE
ONE THERE'S ANYONE ONLINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. NINETEEN OH SIX.
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO FOR
SUPPORT ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE
NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHTS IS
THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF
NINETEEN OH SIX A NO ONE HERE
ANYONE ONLINE ACTION ANYONE IN
TWENTY FORTY SINGLE WHEN
THEY'RE ANYONE ONLINE. IN
OPPOSITION OF NINETEEN OH SIX.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHTS
FARMING FINANCE DO YOU HAVE A
FILE. THANK YOU SEE THIS YEAR
INDICATES THE COST TO IMPLEMENT
THIS BILL ARE UNKNOWN THAT
COULD RANGE FROM FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
IN MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY SIX
YEAR AMENDED ITS LIMITED TERM
LIGHT DUTY ASSIGNMENT
REGULATIONS AND ADOPTED
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS.
PERTAINING TO TEMPORARY
MODIFIED WORK ASSIGNMENTS. THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
INCLUDES SIXTEEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ON
A LIMITED TERM BASIS. THESE
CHANGES- SO WHILE THE FUNDING
IS LIMITED TERM THE PROVISIONS
OF THIS BILL ARE NOT- AND WOULD
RESULT IN UNFUNDED LIABILITY IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
AND I'M GOING. ALL RIGHT SINGLE
QUESTIONS BY ANYBODY AB
NINETEEN OH SIX WILL GO TO.
SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE SIR
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT
SEEING NONE IS OR ANYONE IN
TWENTY FORTY. THANKS FOR SAYING
NINE TWENTY ONE ONLINE FREE
LEAD NINETEEN TWENTY THREE. I
GOT MY. IS A LITTLE COLD ALWAYS
CHILLY. SEEING KNOWN AS MR
MODERATOR EITHER. I'M SPEAKING
WITH MY MUTE ON IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO THIS IS
AB NINETEEN TWENTY THREE. AND
WE HAVE NOBODY IN TWO. CORRECT
THERE'S NO ONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF NINETEEN TWENTY
THREE TWENTY ONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SEEING NO ONE THERE IS
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB NINETEEN
TWENTY THREE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ACTUALLY THIS
PROPOSITION ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHTS IS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WILL
FILE A MAYBE NINETEEN TWENTY
THREE. YES THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AN ESTIMATED COST
OF FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE BUILDING
STANDARDS ADMINISTRATION
SPECIAL REVOLVING FUND IN THE
FIRST YEAR. AND TWO HUNDRED
ELEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS THE
SECOND YEAR. ALL RIGHT SINGLE
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
AB NINETEEN TWENTY THREE GOES
TO SUSPENSE AB NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE EMERGENCY SERVICES FIRST
RESPONDERS. SEEING NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM IS OR ANYONE IN
TWENTY FORTY THAT WISHES TO
SPEAK. IN SUPPORT OF NINETEEN
FORTY FIVE. C. NO ONE THERE'S
ONLY NE IN THE QUEUE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE MIN ZERO. ONE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NOBODY IN Q. ALL
RIGHT OPPOSITION HERE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE OPPOSITION IN
TWENTY FORTY. NOBODY CARES OR
ANY OPPOSITION CUED UP ON
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES INDICATES MINOR
DURABLE MINOR MINOR EDITS OR
WILL COSTS IN ADDITION BOTH
CALPERS AND CAL H. R. INDICATE
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE ANY
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE RETIREMENT
PENSION FORMULAS OR EMPLOYEE
CLASSIFICATIONS HOWEVER WE
WOULD NOTE THAT BY CLASSIFYING
A PUBLIC SAFETY DISPATCHER OR
PUBLIC SAFETY TO A COMMUNICATOR
AS A FIRST RESPONDER THAT THIS
BILL COULD RESULT IN FUTURE
COST. TO EXTEND THIS DEFINITION
LEADS TO AN AGO SHE XIN FOR
ENHANCED SALARIES OR BENEFITS.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU SEE NO
QUESTIONS. WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE FOR THE
SUSPENSE AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY
THREE. ON BIOMETHANE
PROCUREMENT. SEE NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM IN SUPPORT ANYBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT SAYING
ONLINE. IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE MIN ZERO FOUR SUPPORT.
ONE ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE A FEW
QUEUING UP JUST BE A MOMENT
HERE OUR FIRST LINE WILL BE
LINE ONE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JULIA
LEVINS WITH THE BIOENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT SH THIS BILL
DOES NOT CREATE A MANDATE OR
NEW COST TO FLOWERS TO QC TO
CONSIDER A BROADER RANGE OF
BIOMETHANE SOURCES. OUR LITTLE
QUALITY RECOMMENDED TO CHANGE
TWICE WHEN IT IS RECOMMENDED IN
ALL OF THE STATE'S KIND THAT
PLANNED SO WE FIRST COMMITTEE
TO. THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS BRIAN
KENNEY WITH CLEAN ENERGY ALSO
IN SUPPORT AND ALSO LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT IF THEM WE A
CORPORATION I HAD A NO COST
ESTIMATE FOR THE BILL WE
BELIEVE THAT THE BILL WILL BE
VERY GOOD FOR THE STATE THANK
YOU. THIS IS THE SENATE. NEXT
WEEK- PLEASE DO ME TOO AT THIS
POINT THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO THE LINE ONE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS MANY BY YOUNG ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL GAS VEHICLE COALITION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT IS
LINE ONE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS JULIA HALL WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES HERE IN PART THANK YOU.
OUR FINAL IN Q. IS LINE ONE
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS LARDED
HE MENACE BUT STILL COMCAST IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY ONE
SIXTY THREE. ALL RIGHT AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT
THERE'S NO ONE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE THAT SUPPOSES OR ANYONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY THIS IS
THE TIME FOR OPPOSITION. SIGNAL
WHEN THRE'S ANYONE QUEUED UP
IN OPPOSITION. OF AB THIRTY ONE
SIXTY THREE. PRESS ONE ZERO IF
YOU WISH TO OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE
QUEUING UP JUST ONE MOMENT.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS JAMIE GO ON
BEHALF OF CAFE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE.
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
SIERRA CLUB LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
AND ENERGY SHE IN SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION I'M SORRY. ALL RIGHT
ARE YOU SURE. OPPOSITION OKAY
ANYONE ELSE. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
IN Q. ALL RIGHT FROM THE
FINANCE. IF YOU HAVE THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION DOES NOT
ANTICIPATE A FISCAL IMPACT FROM
THIS BILL. WILL BE NOTE THAT TO
THE EXTENT CLEANER SOURCES SUCH
AS BIOGAS ARE MORE COSTLY THAN
TRADITIONAL FOSSIL FUELS WORLD
FOR ALTERNATIVE SOURCES SUCH AS
SOLAR- INCORPORATING THESE
CLEANER SOURCES INTO THE MIX OF
FUEL SUPPLIES. COULD INCREASE
COSTS TO RATEPAYERS. ALL RIGHTS
SIGNAL ONE ON THE COMMITTEE
WITH QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION. I'M SORRY FACT
DECIDE NOT A QUESTION JUST A
STATEMENT I COMMENT ON. THE
ISSUE REGARDING THE COSTS I
KEEP GETTING I'VE GOTTEN
SEVERAL INQUIRES ON THAT SO I
JUST WANT TO PUT IT ON THE
RECORD YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH.
TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT THAT IF
WE MIGHT AS WE YOU KNOW GET TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE. BECAUSE THE
IN THE I THINK IT JUST NEEDS TO
BE A LITTLE BETTER TO FIND A
RATHER THAN COGS PRESSURE.
COULD I JUST ASK FOR THAT. HE
WOULD ENTERTAIN THAT THAT WOULD
BE GREAT FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WOULD DO THAT THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL. YEAH BEING
ABLE RESPOND. WE CAN HAVE STAFF
LOOK AT THE THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. WITHOUT ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AB THIRTY
ONE SIXTY THREE. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO AB THIRTY
TWO OH FIVE. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM SEEING NONE ANYBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEEING
NONE IS ANYONE QUEUED UP IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO OH
FIVE ON REGION'S RISE GRANT
PROGRAM. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT ONE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NOBODY IN Q. ARE
ANY OPPOSITION TO THIRTY TWO OH
FIVE NOBODY'S HERE I'M A TWENTY
FORTY. NOBODY'S THERE HOW ABOUT
ONLINE ANYBODY QUEUED UP IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY TWO OH
FIVE BY MISTER CELIS. PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO IF YOU WISH
TO OPPOSE ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE
NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHT FORMER
FINANCE. THANK YOU MR HERE-
WELL THE BILL IS SUBJECT TO AN
APPROPRIATION WOULD KNOW THAT-
GO THIS ESTIMATES APPROXIMATELY
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND WOULD BE NEEDED
ANNUALLY TO MINISTER THE
PROGRAM TO THE EXTENT IT WAS
FUNDED. ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
RESULTING UNKNOWN BUT LIKELY
SIGNIFICANT A ONE TIME OR
ONGOING A GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO
THE REGIONAL COLLECTIVES. ALL
RIGHT. NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. THAT OBJECTION SB
THIRTY TWO OH FIVE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING TO MISS
WALDRON CALIFORNIA MATT REENTRY
INCENTIVE PROGRAM AB THIRTEEN
OH FOUR. SHE'S WAY PRESENTATION
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY. WANTS
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT NOBODY'S
THERE IS ANYONE QUEUED UP IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO SHOW
SUPPORT. ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE
NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHT AND NO
OPPOSITION IN THIS ROOM IT'S
TIME FOR OPPOSITION IS ANYBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. W.
THERE'S ANYONE QUEUED UP IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN OH
FOUR. PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE
ZERO TO OPPOSE ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NOBODY IN Q. CORRECT
BERMAN FINANCE. THANK YOU THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION ESTIMATES
GENERAL FUND COSTS IN THE LOW
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO COMPLY
WITH THE REQUIREMENTS OF THIS
BILL AND ALTHOUGH THE REDUCTION
OF PAROLE TERMS- MAY RESULT IN
GENERAL FUND SAVINGS A CITIES
HERE ISN'T ABLE TO ESTIMATE THE
SAVINGS PRIMARILY BECAUSE THE
BILL'S EARLY PAROLE DISTRICT
PROVISIONS OVERLAP WITH
EXISTING DEPARTMENTAL POLICY.
FINALLY THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES DIDN'T
ESTIMATE ANY DIRECT COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL. I
DIDN'T KNOW THAT THE FEDERAL
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ADMINISTRATION
A GRANT REFERENCED IN THIS
BILL- HAS ALREADY BEEN
ALLOCATED TO VARIOUS PROJECTS
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT.
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR.
WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING TO
MISS PETRIE-NORRIS MEDI CAL
REIMBURSEMENTS AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN SHE'S WAY
PRESENTATION AS HAVE ALL THE
AUTHORS- SO THERE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN. SEEING NONE ANYBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NINE
ANYONE QUEUED UP. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHT IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN. THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM ANYBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY. ANYBODY ONLINE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE ZERO FOUR
OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO. WE DO
HAVE ONE IN Q. IT'S LINE ONE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IT IS
INTELLIGENCE DID YOU SKIP.
THREE ONE TWO ONE. JUST GIVE US
YOUR NAME AND YOUR POSITION ON
WILL NOTICE. MY NAME IS
KATHLEEN BECKETT I WORDS EITHER
AND AB THREE ONE TWO ONE I WAS
WAITING TO SPEAK ON THAT AND I
DID NOT HEAR THREE ONE TWO ONE
CALL THANK YOU I THANK THE
COMMITTEE WELL NOTED IT'S MUCH
LATER BUT WE'LL KNOW CHU SO
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT ANYONE I
THINK WE'RE ON IN OPPOSITION.
THE THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN. ONCE
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NOBODY IN Q. THIS ONE A
DOUBLE CHECK ANYBODY SUPPORTER
OPPOSED AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN QUEUED UP. THIS IS YOUR
LAST CHANCE IN AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN. SEEING NOBODY-
AND SEEING- DEPARTMENT FINANCE
WHAT YOU HAVE TELL US ABOUT
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR WE'RE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT
RESULTS IN COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE CURRENT FISCAL PLAN AND
BECAUSE THE COST OF REMOVING
THE STATUTORY CAP ON
REIMBURSEMENT RATES. WE FEEL IS
MORE APPROPRIATELY CONSIDERED
ALONGSIDE OTHER CHANGES IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS NEXT YEAR. WE
ESTIMATE ANNUAL COST OF BETWEEN
TWO MILLION AND FORTY POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND OR EXCUSE ME FORTY POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS HALF OF
WHICH WOULD BE GENERAL FUND TO
REMOVE THE STATUTORY CAP ON
REIMBURSEMENT RATES. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NO QUESTIONS THAT
OBJECTION AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY TWO ALSO BY
MISS PETRIE-NORRIS ON STATE
HIGHWAY ROUTE ONE THIRTY THREE.
RELINQUISHMENT SIR ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT SEEING
NONE ANYBODY IN TWENTY. FORTY
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANYONE
ONLINE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY TWO. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHT IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY TWO SAYING
NO ONE HERE ANYBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY. NO ONE THERE ANYBODY IN
THE QUEUE OPPOSED AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY TWO. PLEASE PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE
ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE NOBODY IN
Q. ALL RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN RENEWAL ON THIS
MEASURE- ALTHOUGH THIS COULD
RESULT IN ONE TIME COSTS TO
CALTRANS TO BRING THE PROPOSED
HIGHWAY SEGMENT INTO A STATE OF
GOOD REPAIR IT COULD
ADDITIONALLY RESULT IN SOME
LONG TERM COST SAVINGS- FOR
DECREASED MAINTENANCE WORKLOAD.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY TWO SEEN NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
THAT BILL WILL GO UP IN
SUSPENSE. MOVING TO MISTER CORK
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT
CANNABIS. ANYONE IN THIS ROOM.
NO ONE HERE ANYBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. SIGNAL WHEN THERE'S
ANYONE QUEUED UP IN SUPPORT OF
AB FOURTEEN. FIFTY EIGHT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO INTEREST
TO SHOW SUPPORT ONE ZERO. AND
WE HAVE NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHT
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION SEEING
NOBODY HEARS ANYBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY OPPOSED. TO FOURTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT. HELLO ANYBODY
ONLINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE
ZERO IF YOU WISH CHAU
OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ALLEN'S
YOU KNOW FILE ANY COMMON SEEING
NONE WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT WE'LL GO
TO SUSPENSE AB TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED- MISTER CORK ON CLIMATE
CHANGE AND INFRASTRUCTURE. IS
THEIR SUPPORT HERE NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM HELP OUT TWENTY FORTY.
NOBODY THERE HAVE AN ONLINE
ANYBODY QUEUED UP IN SUPPORT OF
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED. PLEASE
PRESS ONE MIN ZERO IF YOU WISH
TO SHOW SUPPORT. ONE ZERO. AND
WE HAVE NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHT
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED. ANYBODY
IN TWENTY FOUR BY TWENTY FORTY.
ANYBODY ONLINE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO FOR OPPOSITION.
ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVEN'T NO ONE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT BERMAN
FINANCIAL FILING TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED. YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY ESTIMATES MINOR
OBSERVABLE COSTS TO COORDINATE
THE WORKING GROUP ADDITIONALLY
ANY WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED- FOR
THE OTHER STATE AGENCIES IS
LIKELY TO BE MINOR AMOUNTS OF
RUBBLE WE WOULD NOTE HOWEVER
THAT THE OUTCOMES FROM THE
WORKING GROUP BACKED WORKING
GROUP'S ACTIVITIES MAY RESULT
IN FUTURE COSTS. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING TO MISTER LOWE AB.
FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE COURT
REPORTERS. SIR SUPPORT NOBODY'S
HERE OUR IN TWENTY FORTY.
NOBODY'S THERE IS ANYBODY
ONLINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT. ONE ZERO. WE HAVE
NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY HERE
ABOUT TWENTY FORTY OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY. FOURTEEN SIXTY
NINE. NOBODY IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
ANYBODY IN THE QUEUE A POST AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE MIN ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHT
FORMER FINANCE. I DON'T KNOW
FILE DOES ANYBODY HAVE A
QUESTION NOPE WITHOUT OBJECTION
FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN
ON REFUGEES SPECIAL IMMIGRATION
VISA HOLDERS PROFESSIONAL
LICENSING SAID NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM. IN SUPPORT HAVE A TWENTY
FORTY. NOBODY THERE IN SUPPORT
HOW ABOUT ONLINE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT ONE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NOBODY
QUEUEING UP. ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM HAVE A TWENTY FORTY.
NOBODY DARES ANYBODY QUEUED UP
THAT WOULD LIKE TO OPPOSE AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE KNOWN IN Q. ALL RIGHT
FORMER FINANCE. MINISTER HERE
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS INDICATES THAT
EXPEDITING APPLICATIONS IS
PRIMARILY HANDLED THROUGH
BOARDS BUSINESS PROCESS AND CAN
BE ACCOMPLISHED WITHOUT ANY
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY IMPACT-
HOWEVER- IF BOARDS. THAT CHOOSE
TO AUTOMATE THE TRACKING OF
THESE RATHER INFORMATION IT
COULD RESULT IN A ONE TIME
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY IMPACTS
RANGING FROM NEGLIGIBLE TO FORM
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SEE NO ONE PUT
COMMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN. SO THE
SUSPENSE MOVIE IN AB TWO TWO
EIGHT EIGHT OUR NURSING
PROGRAMS. THERE'S NO ONE IN THE
SHERMAN SUPPORT ANYBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. NO ONE THERE
ANYONE UP ON KEY IN Q. IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO FOR SUPPORT ONE ZERO. CAN
WE HAVE NOBODY QUEUEING UP ALL
RIGHT OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM ABOUT TWENTY FORTY.
NOBODY THERE TWENTY ONE QUEUED
UP IN OPPOSITION OF TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO FOR OPPOSITION ONE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT PARTNER FINANCIAL
FILE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
INDICATES THE BILL MAY RESULT
IN A MINOR INCREASE IN WORKLOAD
FOR THE BOARD TO APPROVE
REQUESTS- BUT DOES ALSO NOTE
THAT THE BOARD PLANS TO TRACK
THESE PRE LICENSURE NURSING
INFORMATION IN ITS INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEM- WHICH MAY
RESULT IN UNKNOWN. RIGHT SHE
COSTS- ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
BILL. ALL RIGHT SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT. MISTER
LOGO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE TO
MISTER CUNNINGHAM AB FIFTEEN
NINETY NINE PEACE OFFICERS
INVESTIGATIONS. AND MISCONDUCT
IS THERE ANYONE IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NO ONE HERE SIR ANYONE.
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. NO ONE
THERE IS THERE ANYONE ONLINE IN
SUPPORT OF FIFTEEN NINETY NINE.
PLEASE PRESSONE BUTTON ZERO
FOR SUPPORT ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY HERE OPPOSE TIME OUT
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. NOBODY THERE
HOW ABOUT ONLINE IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE KNOWN IN Q. ALL RIGHTS IS
THERE FILE. S. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION
ON THIS BILL THAT WOULD NOTE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
ESTIMATES ANNUAL COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND FOR THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL AT THE CALIFORNIA WAY
TROLL LESTER ANNUAL OF NINETY
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
FOR THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL. AND LASTLY THE BILL MAY
IMPOSE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE BY REQUIRING ALL LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
COMPLETE AN ADMINISTRATIVE
INVESTIGATION OF ALL OF AN
AWESOME OFFICER RETIRES OR
RESIGNS PRIOR TO THE COMPLETION
OF THE INVESTIGATION ALL THE
POTENTIAL MAGNITUDE OF THIS
BAND IT IS UNKNOWN BUT COULD BE
SIGNIFICANT. RIGHT LOCAL. ARE
CALM WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB
FIFTEEN NINETY NINE. SCHOOLS OF
FISH SUSPENSE MOVIES TO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN ON
EMERGENCY RESOURCE. LITHIUM
EXTRACTION IN CALIFORNIA A. B.
SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE
AM HERE NOBODY'S HEREAND
SUPPORT HAVE A TWENTY FORTY.
NOBODY THERE IS THERE ANYBODY
QUEUED UP IN SUPPORT. OF PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU WISH
TO SHOW SUPPORT ONE ZERO. AND
WE HAVE KNOWN IN Q. ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION TO SIXTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY HERE HOW
BOUT TWENTY FORTY. NOBODY THERE
HOW BOUT IN THE QUEUE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO. WHEN WE
HAVE KNOWN IN Q. ALL RIGHT FROM
A FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF THE ENERGY COMMISSION
INDICATES COSTS OF ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND ONE POSITION TO CONVENE THE
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
INTRODUCED THE RECORD REPORT
HOWEVER BECAUSE THE BILL
REQUIRES THE ENERGY COMMISSION
TO IMPLEMENT ITS PROVISIONS
WITHIN EXISTING RESOURCES- THEY
WOULD NEED TO REPRIORITIZE
THEIR EXISTING RESOURCES TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT SEE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN. WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING TO TWENTY SIX SIXTY
THREE. ON FUEL TAX MONEY.
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT ANYBODY TWENTY FORTY IN
SUPPORT. ANYBODY QUEUED UP IN
SUPPORT OF TWENTY SIX SIXTY
THREE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT ONE ZERO. AND
WE HAVE NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHTS.
FORMER FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION STATES THAT
FUTURE REVENUE IMPACTS ARE
UNKNOWN BECAUSE THIS TYPE OF
FUEL IS NOT CURRENTLY SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA I GIVEN THAT IT'S
NOT CURRENTLY APPROVED FOR
COMMERCIAL SALE BUY THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD. AT THE C. T.
F. A. ALSO ESTIMATES- LIKELY
MINOR AN OBSERVABLE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. LASTLY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE A STATES IT WILL
NEED TO MODIFY ITS EXISTING
PROCEDURES FOR THE SAMPLING AND
ANALYSIS OF THIS TYPE OF FUEL-
BUT THEY BELIEVE THAT WOULD BE
ABLE TO MANAGE THESE ADDITIONAL
EXPENSES WITHIN THEIR EXISTING
RESOURCES. RIGHT SHAUNA MAKE
SURE I TOOK BOTH OPPOSITION AND
SUPPORT ONLINE ANYBODY IN THE
QUEUE. ON TWENTY SIX SIXTY
THREE. ONE LAST TIME BOB PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU'D
LIKE TO MAKE A OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE NOBODY IN
Q. ALL RIGHT WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY THREE WILL
GO. DURING EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS ANYONE IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY HERE HOW BY
TWENTY FORTY. NOBODY THERE IS
ANYBODY IN THE QUEUE IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY THREE OH SEVEN.
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSE TIME OUT ROOM
TWENTY FORTY OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTY THREE OH SEVEN SEEING
NONE ANYBODY IN THE QUEUE
OPPOSED AB THIRTY THREE OH
SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT IS THERE A FINANCE REPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YES
ASSUMING A SIMILAR SIZE AND
SCALE TO SOME OF ITS OTHER
PROGRAMS AT THE I THINK
ESTIMATES ANNUAL COST
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A TO SUPPORT
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL-
WOULD KNOW THAT IT'S UNCLEAR
WHETHER THESE COSTS CAN BE
SUPPORTED BY THE APPLICATION
FEES. AND FURTHER WHETHER THE%
APPLICATION FEES WILL BE
SUFFICIENT TO COVER THE COST.
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR SINGLE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
THIRTY THREE OH SEVEN. WE'RE
GOING TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO MS
BONNER HER FOR BATH. AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. WORK
SHARING. IS THERE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY HERE HOW
ABOUT IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
NOBODY HOW ABOUT ONLINE. FOR
ANYONE ONLINE WHO IS IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE
NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHTS ARE
OPPOSITION AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
ONE BOERNER HORVATH. NOBODY
HERE TWENTY FORTY NOBODY THERE
IS ANYBODY IN THE QUEUE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE MIN ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE CAN WE
JUST DROP NEVER MIND WE HAVE
KNOWN IN Q. ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YES HE
DID HE'S STILL DEVELOPING A
COST ESTIMATE FOR THIS BILL BUT
IT DOES INDICATE THAT THE
REQUIREMENT TO ELECTRONICALLY
FORWARD CLAIM PACKAGE TO NEWLY
APPROVED EMPLOYERS MAY RESULT
IN UNKNOWN BUT SIGNIFICANT
COSTS. EDT REPORTS AN ONLINE
PORTAL JUST A NETWORK SHARING
PLAN APPLICATION ALREADY EXISTS
SO NO ADDITIONAL COSTS TO BE
INCURRED FOR BEST FOR THAT
PROVISION AND FINALLY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS A SCAM AND
DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATE COSTS
WOULD BE MINOR. LOCAL RIGHT. ON
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE SING NINE
WITHOUT OBJECTION. A. B.
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE FOUR GO TO
SUSPENSE MR LEVINE AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY SIX. ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS.
SIR ANYONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT SAYING NO ONE HERE HAVE
A TWENTY FORTY NO ONE THERE HOW
ABOUT ONLINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT
ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE NOBODY IN
Q. ALL RIGHT ANY OPPOSITION TO
SEVENTEEN NINETY SIX SEEN
NOBODY HERE ANYBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY. SO ANYBODY ONLINE. IN
OPPOSED TO AB. SEVENTEEN NINETY
SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO. AND
WE HAVE NOBODY IN Q. BERMAN
FINANCE. IS THE DIGITAL COUNCIL
ESTIMATES A SIGNIFICANT ONE
TIME FISCAL IMPACT TO THE
COURTS OF POTENTIALLY RANGING
FROM THE MID HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS TO LOW MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO INSTALL AN AFTER
HOURS DROPBOX OF FACILITIES
THAT RECEIVED A SPECIFIED
PETITIONS FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS. IN ADDITION
CERTAIN COURT COUNTIES OPERATE
MULTIPLE COURT LOCATIONS WHICH
WOULD REQUIRE A JOB DROP BOX TO
INSTALL EACH COURTHOUSE WHILE
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL STILL
DEVELOPING A TOTAL STATE WIDE
ESTIMATE WE WOULD KNOW THAT THE
LOS ANGELES SUPERIOR COURT
ALONE I WILL INCUR COSTS ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
INSTALL DROPBOX. SHE NO HANDS
GO UP WITH OBJECTION AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY SIX. WE'LL GO
TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO. MS WEBER
AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE ON
EDUCATION FINANCE. WE HAVE A
LEAD OPPOSITION WHICH HOPEFULLY
IS BEING QUEUED UP BUT BEFORE
THAT LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANYBODY HERE IN SUPPORT. OF AB
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE SOMEONE IN
THIS ROOM AB TWENTY FORTY.
NOBODY THERE IS THERE ANYBODY
ONLINE SUPPORT OF AB. THIRTY
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE. SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE WERE
LINE ONE EIGHTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I MEAN MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA. FIX
GOOGLE NINE ONE THIRTY THREE
YOUR OPEN. AARON BE WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT. AND ONE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIVE ONE FIFTY FIVE ARE YOU
MUTED. GOOD AFTERNOON THE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS HELLO AGAIN IT'S
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
FIVE. BUT WE WANT ONE FIFTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LEARN GREGORY
KRAMER WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. AND LINE
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I DIDN'T YEAH WELL YOU
EMPLOY A DOCK CALIFORNIA EIGHT
O'CLOCK BANDWIDTH IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE. AND THERE
ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT WE ARE GOING TO GO TO OUR
LEAD. UP OPPOSITION. THE CENTER
OF THE CHURCHES OR BRUSHES I
DON'T KNOW IF I'M PRONOUNCING
IT CORRECTLY SHE'S NOT IN THERE.
THIS VOTER THE GOING TO THE
NORMAL OPPOSITION IF. HELLO
SUSHI'S IN THE QUEUE OKAY SIR
ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED NO
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FOURTEEN. NO
WE'LL GO TO OUR FULL LINE OF
OPPOSITION TO AB. EIGHTEEN
THIRTY FIVE AND MAYBE SERRA
WILL BE THERE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
OPPOSITION. ONE MOMENT. AND WE
WERE LINE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. BURNAND
SERRA BOTCHES THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS AND OPPOSITION OUR
POSITION DOES NOT SIGNIFY A
LACK OF COMMITMENT TO SERVING
OUR ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS AT ALL OTHER THAN THAT
THAT'S PART OF THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
UNFORTUNATELY EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
THIRTY FIVE CREATES NEW COSTS
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COUNTY
OFFICES BY REQUIRING A NEW
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS TO
RECONCILE AND REPORTS
SUPPLEMENTAL CONCENTRATION
GRANT FIVE. GT ADDING A NEW
ADMINISTRATIVE LAYER AND REVIEW
AND PROCESSING FISCAL RECORDS I
MOVED AWAY FROM THE INTENDED
GOAL OF INCREASING AND
IMPROVING SERVICES FOR OUR
STUDENTS WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE.
UPDATED IT WOULD HAVE REQUIRED
AT LEAST TRIED TO. WITH AND NEW
UPDATED AT. EIGHT ALL THE
TECHNICAL DEBT BUT CLAN ACTION
AND THEN PUT ON. ALSO ALLOWING
THAT EARLY AGE DEMONSTRATE IN
THEIR STATEMENTS WHY THEY HAVE
DEVIATED FROM THOSE ACTIONS
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF COLD
THE NINETEEN WE HAVE SUSPENDED
BENEATH THE USE OF THE NEW
TEMPLATE. WE AGAIN HAVE TO
UNFORTUNATELY OPPOSED EIGHTEEN
THIRTY FIVE BECAUSE THE WALKS
AWAY FROM THE LCF STRUCTURE TO
IMPROVE AND INCREASE SERVICES
TO OUR STUDENTS. ARE RETURNED
TO CATEGORICAL BUDGET
APPROACHED MELENDEZ ITSELF.
AWAY FROM FOCUSING ON OUR
STUDENTS. NEEDS YEAH. I RIGHT
IS THERE ANYWAY ELSE. WHO IS
OPPOSED TO THIS TIME AB.
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE. NOBODY
ELSE HAS QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHTS
SEEING NO QUESTION- DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE A. B. EIGHTEEN
THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE AS A CREATE SIGNIFICANT
ON IN COSTS FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES BY
REQUIRING THEM TO RECONCILE
REPORT AND SPENT SUCH LANOLIN
CONCENTRATION GRANT PLANS TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF WE KNOW THAT
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
MADE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS TO
IMPROVE AND STRENGTHEN OF CFF
FISCAL ACCOUNTABILITY. ON AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHT THE NEW EL CAP
TEMPLATE- BY THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION PROVIDES MORE
TRANSPARENCY AROUND HOW THESE
GRANT FUNDS ARE BEING USED TO
THE LOCAL LEVEL. FINALLY ON
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE. THE L.
A.'S TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO THEIR ACCOUNTING
SYSTEMS PROCESS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR SAYING NO
QUESTIONS. WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB THIRTY ONE. TWENTY
ONE BY MISS WEBER TASK FORCE TO
STUDY DEVELOP. REPARATION
PROPOSALS FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS- IS THERE ANY SUPPORT
NO ONE'S IN THIS ROOM HAVE A
TWENTY FORTY. NO ONE THERE HOW
ABOUT ONLINE. SHOW YOUR SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AND WE WERE LINE ONE
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ANNE MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
I AM MOVING ON WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT. FIND ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT ARE YOU MUTED. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES OKAY THE
DAM WILLIAMS WHERE A DOG
CALIFORNIA A DOG LOCKED
SENSELESS AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE ONE TWO ONE. THANK YOU
ONE ONE NINETY SIX YOU ARE OPEN.
THE OFFICIAL REQUIRE WITH
EIGHTY O. AS LOS ANGELES AND
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE. YES ON
THE BILL. AND LINE ONE NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M CARLY
JENKINS FROM EIGHTY OS LOS
ANGELES I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT.
BY ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOU ARE ALL
BUT. HI EVAN JOSIAH WILLIAMS
WITH A DEAL S. CALIFORNIA
EIGHTY- IT BAY AREA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE
NINETY THREE. THIS IS MARKET
SHARE BEING EIGHTY WEST LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY
ONE. ONE BY ONE FIFTY SIX YOU
ARE UP QUARRELSOME ATO ACROSS
ANGELES EIGHTY WHAT CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
ONE POINT ONE. THANK YOU. AND
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR. HI THIS IS
CRYSTAL GORDON WITH ATLS LOS
ANGELES AND EIGHTY OS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE SEVENTY NINE YOU ARE ALL
BUT. TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ME YES HELLO
BY THIS IS BEVERLY BY THEIR LAN
AND I'M WITH EIGHTY- AT WHAT
THEY HAD TO LIVE AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY
ONE. TEXAS LINE ONE NINETY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MARJORIE MELVIN I'M WITH EIGHT
AUSTIN LANE EMPIRE AND I
SUPPORT A. B. THIRTY ONE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND WE WILL ALIGN ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE. HI THIS IS KIM NAM
EIGHT OH SACRAMENTO IN AID OF
CALIFORNIA FOLLY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL A. B.
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE
VOTE YEAH THANK YOU. M. MISTER
CHAIR THERE'S NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION THERE'S
NO ONE IN THIS ROOM HOW BOUT
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SOMEBODY
THERE HAVE ON ONLINE. DIGITAL
YOUR OPPOSITION THAT'S ONE
SMALL BUT. AND NOBODY IS GOING
UP THE STRUCTURE. ALL RIGHTS
FROM DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. ALTHOUGH NOT
SPECIFICALLY MENTIONED IN THE
BILL IT IS ANTICIPATED THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WILL
PROVIDE THE SUPPORT REQUIRED IN
STILL AT AN ESTIMATED COST OF
SEVEN HUNDRED NINETY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE A
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
ONE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE AND SEVENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS I TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. TWENTY FOUR. WE
ALSO NOTE THIS BILL RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES. TO COVER THE PER
DIEM COMPENSATION COSTS FOR THE
TASK FORCE MEMBERS. A SINGLE
HANDS GO UP FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING TO MR MEDINA AB
NINETEEN THIRTY. THIRTY SUPPORT
SAYING NO ONE HERE HOW BOUT
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. YOU KNOW
WHEN THEY'RE ANYBODY ONLINE.
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTER NUMEROUS THE
JOHNSON WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. NINE ANY OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE IN THIS ROOM MAY BE
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN. SEE NON
THERE ANYBODY ONLINE. OPPOSED
TO AB NINETY ONE THIRTY. THANK
YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO TO SHOW THEIR
OPPOSITION. NOBODY IS KILLING
UP SIR. SAY NO ONE WAS GIVING
UP. ALL RIGHT NOT AT THIS TIME
SIR ALL RIGHT BERMAN FINANCE.
THANK YOU ALTHOUGH THE BILL
REQUIRES THE IMPACTED ENTITIES
TO IMPLEMENT ITS PROVISIONS
WITHIN EXISTING RESOURCES. OR
ANY KIND OF BOARD OF TRUSTEES
OR REGENTS CONSIDER THE
ADDITION OF NEW UNDERGRADUATE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS OF THE
UC AND CSU INDICATE ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES A
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND BETWEEN ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION TO ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS RESPECTIVELY A
TO CONVENE AN IMPLEMENTATION
COMMITTEE AND CONTRACT FOR AN
INDEPENDENT EVALUATION BY A
THIRD PARTY. ADDITIONALLY THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE INDICATES
UNKNOWN A ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
COST PRESSURES. ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS MEASURE. SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB
NINETEEN THIRTY WATER SUSPENSE
MOVIE MISTER KALRA AB NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN EMPLOYMENT
VIOLATION COMPLAINTS. C. KNOWN
IN THE SHERMAN SUPPORT ANYBODY
IN TWENTY FORTY. NO ONE THERE
ANYBODY ONLINE. SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP MISTER CARE AREN'T
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY HERE
ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
NO ONE THERE ANYBODY ONLINE
OPPOSED TO NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN.
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. NOBODY IS QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHTS.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. MISTER
CHAIR THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS ESTIMATES
COSTS TOTALING ONE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS TO ONE POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS INITIALLY-
AND ONE MILLION TO ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
IN THE LABOR ENFORCEMENT AND
COMPLIANCE FUND. C. NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION. NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN MY MISTER KALRA
WILL GO THE SUSPENSE MOVING TO.
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY TWO. ON
FUNERAL ARRANGEMENTS IS THERE
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT. SEEING
KNOWN IN THIS ROOM ANYBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NINE
ANYONE ONLINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT.
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT
ANY OPPOSITION NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM. ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
THE MONEY ONLINE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
YOUR OPPOSITION. NO ONE IS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IN
FACT. LOW FILE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS AB. TWENTY THREE
THIRTY TWO FOR THE SUSPENSE.
MOVING TO MR CHIU. THREE B.
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE. CONTROL
THE BEAUCE PORTING THERE'S NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT.
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY. AND
ANYBODY ONLINE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT ANY
OPPOSITION IN THIS ROOM NINE
TWENTY FORTY. NONE ANY
OPPOSITION ONLINE. THE SHOW
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME. FORMER
FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ANTICIPATES ANNUAL COSTS UP TO
NINETEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND FOR PROCESSING AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
ARRESTS FINGERPRINTS AND
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD- WE BELIEVE
THAT THESE COSTS ARE LIKELY
IT'S HORRIBLE AN EXISTING
RESOURCES. ADDITIONALLY BY
BILL COULD HAVE AN IMPACT ON
THE COUNTY JAIL POPULATION
ALTHOUGH AT THE IMPACT JUST
LIKE THE MINOR. SHINO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION A. B.
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE. BY MR
TRUE WITHOUT A FENCE MOVING TO.
AB. TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT.
JOHN ATHLETES AGENTS AND HEALTH
AND SAFETY THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT ANYBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY. NO ONE THERE.
ANYBODY IN ONLINE IN THE QUEUE
IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT. THREE PAGES TO GO.
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT
ANY OPPOSITION TO TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT NOBODY'S IN THIS
ROOM HOW ABOUT ANYBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY. ANYBODY ONLINE.
IF YOU PRESS ONE ZERO TO SHOW
OPPOSITION. NOBODY IS QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME BERMAN FINANCE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES INCREASED ONGOING
ANNUAL COSTS LESS THAN TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO PROCESS AN
INCREASE IN A RESTAURANT OR
PRINTING AND ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD. I WOULD ALSO NOTE BY
EXPANDING THE EXISTING SCOPE
WITH A MISDEMEANOR CRIME STILL
COULD IMPOSE ADDED COSTS
WORKLOAD ON COURTS AND COUNTIES
WHICH COULD CREATE ADDITIONAL
FISCAL PRESSURE ON THE LOCAL
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. ALL
RIGHT SEE NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING TO A. B.
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE FIVE. MS
RUBIO. ON SECOND HAND GOODS
REPORTING. THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT ANYBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY NO ONE THERE
ANYBODY ONLINE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY HERE HOW ABOUT TWENTY
FORTY. NOBODY THERE ANYBODY
ONLINE IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
FINANCE GOLD DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ESTIMATES COSTS OF
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
SECOND HAND DEALER AND
PAWNBROKER FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO PERFORM DATABASE
UPGRADES AND MODIFICATIONS TO
COMPLY WITH THE MANDATES IN THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING TO MS EGGMAN
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. THERE
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM KNOW WHAT
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY IN
SUPPORT. NO ANYBODY ONLINE IN
SUPPORT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT ONE ZERO. AFTER. WE DO
HAVE ONE THAT'S COMING UP WOULD
JUST BE A MOMENT. WE'RE GOING
TO LINE AT ONE EIGHT EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOUR SON ON THE
STANISLAUS AND THE MOTHER OF
ADULT TWENTY DOLLARS WHICH GETS
A PRETTY. STRONGLY SUPPORT.
EIGHTY NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX.
THANK YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN PRESS
ONE ZERO. FOR SUPPORT NO. OKAY
IT'S ANOTHER. I THINK. WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. WOULD JUST
BE A MOMENT WHEN WE GIVE THEM
THEIR LINE NUMBER. IF OKAY. HE
SAID IT WAS ONE MORE NO. THERE
IS ONE MORE THEY'RE GETTING
THEIR LINE NUMBER. OKAY WE'RE
GOING TO LINE ONE FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS QUENTIN
THEM CALLING PRESENT EAGLE
COUNTY I MISSED A SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS ADVOCATE I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX. IT WILL EXPAND AND
STRENGTHEN EVIDENCE BASED COST
EFFECTIVE ASSISTED OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA HELPING ADULTS WITH
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS AND
COMPROMISED DECISION MAKING
CAPACITY WITH PSYCHOSIS. TO GET
MORE IMMEDIATE MEDICAL
TREATMENT AND KEEP THEM OUT OF
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IN
OFF THE STREET. SIGNS TELL THE
LONGER A PERSON IS IN THE
UNTREATED PSYCHOSIS THE MORE
BRAIN DAMAGE OCCURS AS YOU
STROKES. A. O. T. ENABLES
FAMILIES TO GET THEIR LOVED
ONES TREATMENT BEFORE TRAGEDY
AGAINST PEOPLE WITH SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS THEIR LIVES BACK
BOTH. FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT
ANY OPPOSITION TO NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX THERE'S NOBODY HERE
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY. NOBODY
THERE ANYBODY QUEUED UP IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO TO OPPOSE ONCE AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. WE DO OF
ONE PERSON THAT'S QUEUING. UP
JUST A MOMENT WHEN WE GIVE THEM
THEIR LINE NUMBER. MY NUMBER
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
MOMENT. MR THAT AGAIN NINE ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CONNIE DELGADO IN BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTOR THE USUAL OPPOSITE.
ALL RIGHT ANYONE OUT WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT BERMAN
FINANCE. THANK YOU AND IT
APARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ESTIMATES GENERAL FUND
COSTS ABOUT TWO TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER. TO ADDRESS
THE WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH UP
TO AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY NINE
COUNTIES PARTICIPATING IN
ASSISTED OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
PROGRAMS. ANYBODY HAVE ANY
COMMENTS NO WITHOUT OBJECTION A
MEANS NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX WILL
GO THE SUSPENSE. MOVING TO AB
NINETEEN NINETY THREE FIVE
MINUTES COM LONGER ON
UNEMPLOYMENT AND DISABILITY
INSURANCE. THERE'S NO ONE IN
THE SHERMAN SUPPORT ANYBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY. NOBODY THERE
ANYBODY IN THE QUEUE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE
KNOWN IN Q. ALL RIGHT ANY
OPPOSITION SEEING NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM ANYBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY. SING NOW ON THEIR
ANYBODY ONLINE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO FOR OPPOSITION
ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. ALL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. MR HERE WE DON'T HAVE
A POSITION ON THIS BILL AT THIS
TIME I AM NOT THE DDT IS STILL
DEVELOPING AN ESTIMATE FOR THIS
BILL BUT WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
LIKELY A SIGNIFICANT-
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS MEASURE. WE KNOW THAT
THE U. I. FUND IS CURRENTLY
INSOLVENT DUE TO RECORD HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT AS A RESULT OF
PANDEMIC- I'M IN THE STATE IS
BORROWING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO CONTINUE YOU AYE
BENEFIT PAYMENTS. SIX EXPANDING
YOUR ELIGIBILITY WITH. CHRIS
CLAIMS AGAINST THE FUND.
FURTHER EXACERBATING ITS
CONDITION AND INCREASING THE
STATE'S FEDERAL YOU AYE LOAN
BALANCE. IN A SOCIAL SERVICES
IS ALSO. DOING DEVELOP ITS
ESTIMATES OF THE IMPACT ON I
JUST US. BASED ON INFORMATION
PROVIDED BY EDG IT IS ESTIMATED
IT WOULD TOTAL TWENTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY A HALF
OF WHICH WOULD BE. SUPPORTED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OVER THE
RESULTING STATE IMPACT OF
APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND ANNUALLY. ANYBODY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS NOW.
WITHOUT OBJECTION NINETEEN
NINETY THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. AB TWO THOUSAND FOUR
MISTER CALDERON MEDICAL TEST
RESULTS. SEEING NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM IN SUPPORT ANYBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT.
ANYBODY ONLINE IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT ONE ZERO. WE DO HAVE
ONE IN Q. IT'S LINE ONE EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE ONE EIGHTY FOUR
POSSIBLY YOUR MUTE BUTTONS ON.
LATER DROPPED A LINE THERE ARE
THE WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q.
ALL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YOU MISTER CHAIR WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE IT WILL RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT COSTS TO BOTH THE
MEDICAL BOARD AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS-
WELL THE MEDICAL BOARD
ANTICIPATES I KNOW COST OF THE
GENERAL FUND WE WOULD ESTIMATE
THAT ESTABLISHING THE WORKGROUP
WOULD REQUIRE EQUAL OR GREATER
THAN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN COSTS AS WELL AS AT
LEAST SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO HIGHER POSITIONS TO
ASSIST WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION.
OF THE PILOT PROGRAM LASTLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
MAY ALSO INCUR SIGNIFICANT
COSTS HIGHER SUBJECT MATTER
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS AND
CONSULTANTS. FOR THE PROVISIONS
OF THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT I'LL
WANNA MAKE MODERATOR THAT WE
TOOK ALL SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
ONE TWO THOUSAND FOUR. OKAY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. ONE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWO THOUSAND FOUR WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB TWO THOUSAND SIX BY
MR FONG ON STATE HIGHWAY ROUTE
ONE EIGHTY FOUR. IS THERE
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM IN TWENTY FORTY. ANYBODY
ONLINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORT. ONE ZERO. AND
WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ANY
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY HERE
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
SOMEBODY THERE ANYBODY ONLINE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE KNOWN IN Q. ALL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU WERE NEUTRAL ON THIS
MEASURE THE BILL COULD RESULT
IN ONE TIME COSTS TO CALTRANS
TO BRING THE PROPOSED HIGHWAY
SEGMENT INTO A STATE OF GOOD
REPAIR HOWEVER IT ALSO RESULT
RESULT IN LONG TERM SAVINGS TO
THE STATE FOR DECREASED
MAINTENANCE WORKLOAD. HI ALL
RIGHT HE NOBODY RAISING THEIR
HAND WITHOUT OBJECTION AB.
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND SIX WE'LL
GO TO SUSPENSE TO AB TWENTY
THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN ON PROPERTY TAXATION.
SENI SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY
HERE ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
THERE'S NOBODY THERE TWENTY ONE
ONLINE IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY
THIRTEEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORT. ONE ZERO. WE
DO HAVE ONE PERSON THAT'S COULD
UP ITS LINE TWO HUNDRED THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE MOMENT. OKAY LINE TWO
OR THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON DANIELLE CANADA
pELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
MY APOLOGIES I GOT CUT OFF OR.
EIGHTY TWO ZERO ZERO FOUR
CALDERON I WANTED YOU. I
RESPECTFULLY EXPRESS OUR
OPPOSITION TO HELP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FOR ON AB TWENTY
THIRTEEN ANYBODY. IN SUPPORT OF
TWENTY THIRTEEN. PLEASE PRESS
ONE OF THE. ZERO AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION TO TWENTY THIRTEEN
SIGNAL ON IN THIS ROOM ANYBODY
IN TWENTY FOUR TO TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NO ONE THERE ANYONE
ONLINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. I
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- WE'RE NEUTRAL IN
THIS BILL THAT WOULD KNOW
CONCERNED THAT ANY RESULT IN
POTENTIAL FORFEITURE OF FUTURE
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE APPROVED.
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
ESTIMATES ANNUAL PROPERTY TAX
REVENUES MAY BE REDUCED BY UP
TO EIGHT HUNDRED TWENTY DOLLARS
FOR HOME AND UP TO FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PROPERTY
REBUILT FOLLOWING AN ELIGIBLE
EVENT. THIS DOESN'T REPRESENT A
DECREASE IN CURRENT PROPERTY
TAX REVENUE. BUT THE FORFEITURE
OF FUTURE REVENUE GROWTH THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT ANYBODY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS NOW WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWENTY THIRTEEN. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE WE'RE GOING TO BE ONE
TWO THREE FOUR FIVE MORE BILLS
AND I'M GONNA TAKE A SHORT
BREAK. THANK YOUNG MARK FIVE
BORN TO DO FIVE AND THEN TAKE A
SHORT BREAK OKAY. AB TWENTY TWO
OH EIGHT- MISTER ONE ON
CHARITABLE ORGANIZATIONS. IS
THERE SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM. TWENTY FORTY. NOBODY
THERE ANYBODY ONLINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE MIN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
ONE ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON
QUEUING UP MAKE THAT TO THEIR
GET IN THEIR LINE NUMBERS ONE
MOMENT. THIS IS. FIRST GO TO
THE ONE AND ONE THIRTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEERING MEMBERS
FLOORING CAN BE ON BEHALF OF
PAYPAL AND PAYPAL GIVING FUND
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO
EARLY. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE TO
AWAIT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BLIND TWO OH EIGHT
PLEASE SEND ME YOUR CELL. YES
SUCH YOU. OKAY WELL STATE YOUR
NAME. YOUR OWN POWER. WHEN WERE
YOU GIVING UP TO SHOW SUPPORT.
I AM OKAY THE FOUR EIGHT.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE. ARE YOU
MISSED THAT ONE BUT WILL NOTATE
YOUR SUPPORT SO THANK YOU FOR
OUR OWN I THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE ARE ON
AB TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT SUPPORT.
M. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
Q. HI NOT POSITION THE TWENTY
TWO OH WAIT THERE'S NOBODY HERE
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY. NOBODY
THERE ANYBODY IN THE QUEUE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION ONE ZERO. WE HAVE NO
WARNING Q. ALL RIGHT DEPARTMENT
FINANCE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE'RE NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE I
WOULD KNOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ESTIMATES COST OF THREE
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE REGISTRY OF
CHARITABLE TRUSTS FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND SIXTEEN
OR EIGHTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER. WE KNOW
THAT THESE COSTS ARE ESTIMATED
TO BE OFFSET IN PART BY
REGISTRATION ANNUAL RENEWAL AND
OTHER FEES. AUTHORIZED TO BE
CHARGED TO MINISTER ENFORCED
THE BILL'S PROVISIONS. I SEE NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT COACH TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING TO AB TWO FOR
TWENTY FOURTEEN MY MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN. AB TWENTY FOURTEEN
ON MEDICAL MISCONDUCT.
AB
TWENTY FOURTEEN MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN MEDICAL MISCONDUCT
SINGLE ONE HERE IN SUPPORT
ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FOURTEEN.
SEE NOW ON THEIR ANYBODY IN THE
QUEUE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORT ONE ZERO. AND
WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM ANYBODY IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN IN OPPOSITION. ANYBODY
ONLINE IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YES BY
EXTENDING THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS THIS BILL COULD
HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE COUNTY
JAIL POPULATION AS WELL AS THE
STATE PRISON PRISON POPULATION
ALTHOUGH THE NOTE THAT- WE DO
NOT ANTICIPATE A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN EMISSIONS TO STATE
PRISON BUT MORE LIKELY LONGER
PRISON STAYS FOR THOSE WITH A
SUBORDINATE FENCE RELATED TO
THESE CRIMES. ALL RIGHTS SINGLE
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AB TWENTY FOURTEEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
BY MR MAIENSCHEIN ON
TELEHEALTH. THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT ANYBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT.
ANYBODY ONLINE IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. ONE ZERO. WE DO HAVE
ONE THAT'S QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT. AND THAT COMES FROM
LINE TWO OH SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SALAS
ALL REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
CHRONIC YOUR COLLISION AND
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
IN Q. ARE IN OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED.
ANYBODY ONLINE OPPOSED TO AB.
TWENTY THREE SIXTY. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHTS.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL AS A RESULT IN COSTS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT- AND MAY RESULT IN
INCREASED COSTS TO HEALTH PLANS
THAT COULD BE PASSED ON TO
CONSUMERS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES- DO NOT
HAVE AN ESTIMATE AT THE TIME OF
THIS ANALYSIS AND IT'S UNCLEAR
WHETHER MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
PLANS ARE SUBJECT TO THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL. TO
THE EXTENT THAT THEY ARE- WE
ESTIMATE GENERAL FUND AND
FEDERAL FUND COSTS LIKELY IN
THE TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE ESTIMATES
COST OF THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO NINETY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. AND
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER. LASTLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
ESTIMATES ONE TIME COST OF ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM THE INSURANCE FUND. ALL
RIGHT SIGNAL HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWENTY.
THREE SIXTY WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WE WILL MOVE TO MISTER RIVAS AB
TWENTY FORTY THREE ON
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY. AND HEALTH
AGRICULTURAL EMPLOYEES. THERE'S
NOBODY IN HERE IN SUPPORT
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NONE ANYBODY
ONLINE IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY
FORTY THREE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO FOUR SUPPORT ONE ZERO.
SEVEN FOR THE. IN ORDER TO TAKE
A BREAK HELLO. AND WE HAVE NO
IN Q. I RIGHT OPPOSITE TO FOUR
THREE ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
ANYBODY ONLINE OPPOSED TO
TWENTY FORTY THREE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION ONE ZERO. WHAT IS
SPANISH THEN WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. FORMER FINANCE PROBABLY GONE
LONG LONG HELLO SHOULD
ESTIMATES GENERAL FUND COST OF
ONE POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE FIRST YEAR AND SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE
SECOND YEAR TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL. SHE NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWENTY FORTY THREE. WILL GO
ON SUSPENSE AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
FOUR ON TELEHEALTH. ALSO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS- THERE'S
NO ONE IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY. SEEING
NONE ANYONE ONLINE. AND PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. RIGHT FINANCE. THANK YOU MR
HERE WE ESTIMATE ANNUAL GENERAL
FUND COSTS IN THE LOW MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AS A RESULT OF THIS
BILL- AND WITH ADDITIONALLY UP
POTENTIAL SIGNIFICANT JENNIFER
AND COST PRESSURES DEPENDING ON
THE DEMAND FOR TELEHEALTH
SERVICES. FROM FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTERS AND
RURAL HEALTH CLINICS
ADDITIONALLY WE ESTIMATE
THOUSAND COST TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS. TO PROCESS WHAT WAS
SERVICE CHARGE HANGE REQUESTS
AND RECALCULATE RATES RESULTING
FROM THE NEW DEFINITION IN THIS
BILL. SHINO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION THAT BILL WHICH IS AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY FOUR WE'LL GO
TO SUSPENSE WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE A SHORT FIVE MINUTE BREAK.
I HAVE TWO PAGES LEFT OF OUR
EIGHT PAGES SO WILL BE BACK IN
ABOUT FIVE MINUTES EVERYONE SO
WE WILL TAKE A SHORT RECESS.
WE
WILL GO TO AB TWENTY NINETY
TWO. BY RODRIGUEZ ON AMBULANCE.
EMPLOYEE PROTECTIVE GEAR. HE'S
WAY PRESENTATION WE HAVE ONLY
TWO AUTHORS LEFT THAT ARE GOING
TO PRESENT ON OUR TWO PASSES.
EVERYONE ELSE HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION SO IF I DON'T SAY
THAT EVERY TIME I'M SAYING A
PROBLEM THIRTY SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY HERE ANYBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. NOBODY THERE
ANYBODY QUEUED UP IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY NINETY TWO. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
ONE ZERO. THEN WE HAVE NO ONE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM KNOWN
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY. NO
ANYBODY ONLINE OPPOSED TO. AB
TWENTY NINETY TWO. PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOUR
OPPOSITION ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE KNOWN IN Q. ALL RIGHTS
FINANCED YOU HAVE A FILE ON THE
TWENTY. NINETY TWO. SHARE I
THANK YOU THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS ESTIMATES
A ONE TIME COST OF ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM
THE LABOR ENFORCEMENT AND
COMPLIANCE FUND. TO IMPLEMENT
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL.
LADY EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY ESTIMATES MINOR MINOR
AN OBSERVABLE COSTS. ARETINO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWENTY NINETY TWO WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MISTER WOOD HAS TWO
BILLS THE FIRST ONE IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AB TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED AND MEDICARE
DOLLARS ANY SUPPORT IN THE ROOM
SEEN NINE ANY SUPPORT. IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEEING NONE
ANYBODY ONLINE. FOR TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORT. ONE ZERO. WE
DO HAVE A COUPLE QUEUEING UP
ONE MOMENT. OKAY IT WILL GO TO
THE ONE TWO OH SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
TERM MEMBERS CAñADA GOT ONLY
HALF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
REPORT. ON THE OTHER OF OUR
DROPS SO THAT WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN Q. RIGHT OPPOSITION.
CHARLIE OPPOSITION SING NINE
HERE ANY OPPOSITION IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY YEARS OR ANY
OPPOSITION ONLINE FOR AB TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED. PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO FOR OPPOSITION
ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. ALL RIGHT FARMING FINANCE.
THANK YOU MR HERE WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE. THE
GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
ADDITIONALLY- UNTIL THE BILL IS
PREMATURE AS CURRENT EFFORTS BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO SURVEY PHARMACIES
AND DEVELOP A COMPLAINTS AND
GRIEVANCE PROCESS. SHOULD BE
COMPLETED PRIOR TO MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL. LASTLY THE STATUTORY
CREATION OF AN INDEPENDENT
PRESCRIPTION DRUG MEDICAL
REVIEW SYSTEM A SIGNIFICANTLY
LIMITS DEPARTMENTS FLEXIBILITY
TO IMPLEMENT THE PROVISION OF
THE SERVICES IF YOU FOR SERVICE
SYSTEM. OTHER DEPARTMENT
ESTIMATES. I ANNUAL COST OF
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED EIGHTY
NINE MILLION DOLLARS A NINETY
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION OF
WHICH WOULD BE A GENERAL FUND
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT
ESTIMATES COST APPROXIMATELY
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR THE SURVEY REGARDING
SPECIALTY DRUGS AT AN ANNUAL
COST OF ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS HALF OF WHICH
IS GENERAL FUND TO ESTABLISH
AND OPERATE. THE REVIEW SYSTEM.
PRICING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING TO OUR DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY SEVEN. MR WOOD MISTER
HILL WILL BE PRESENTING ON HIS
BEHALF AND YOU CAN DO IT FROM
RIGHT THERE MISTER HILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE TELL US
ABOUT TWENTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN IS A
SIMPLE FIX TO THE INDEPENDENT
DISPUTE RESOLUTION PROCESS THAT
WAS ESTABLISHED IN. OUR TWENTY
SIXTEEN SURPRISED BALANCE
BILLING LEGISLATION THE CHANGES
IN THIS BILL ENSURE THAT THE
REVIEW ORGANIZATION CONSIDER
ONLY INFORMATION SUBMITTED BY
THE DISPUTING PARTIES AND THAT
REVIEWERS ARE ASSIGNED TO EACH
CASE BASED ON THE ROLE OF AN
EDUCATION BACKGROUND AND
EXPERIENCE. IT ALSO ALLOWS FOR
A CONFIDENTIAL PROCESS STATE
REGULATORS REPORT ONE TIME COST
TO IMPLEMENT REGULATIONS OR
CLARIFY THIS BILL WITH EXISTING
PROCESSES IN SUPPORT IS
PRIVATE- PRICE DOUGHERTY FROM
THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS ON THE PHONE.
I HOPE. DO WE HAVE ANY
INDICATION. WE DON'T HAVE THAT
IN OUR SCRIPT ONE. ARE YOU
THERE. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO
THROUGH A ONE MOMENT HERE WE
DID IT WE DID WE DID OF ONE
PERSON QUEUE UP AT THAT TIME
WITH THE ONE ZERO LET ME OPEN
THE LINE TO SEE IF IT HAPPENS
TO BE THEM ONE MOMENT ALL RIGHT
NINE TWO OH FIVE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OPERATES DOUGHERTY. ON BEHALF
OF THE SPONSORS A CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY. OF ANESTHESIOLOGISTS.
LIKE TO BANK A MISTER HELP HER
PRESENTING ON THE BILL AND THE
ONLY THING I'LL ADD THIS. BILL
ALSO SIMPLY CODIFIES. THE
REGULATORY GUIDANCE THAT WAS
ISSUED BY THE DEPARTMENT. TO BE
INDEPENDENT. RESOLUTION ON YOUR
ISSUED IN JANUARY AND CURRENTLY
BEING IMPLEMENTED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AWESOME ANYBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY HERE
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY IN
SUPPORT NOBODY THERE ANYONE
ELSE ONLINE IN SUPPORT. OF AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT. ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN Q. AREN'T ANY
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED AS ANYBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY OPPOSE. FOR ANYONE
ONLINE OPPOSED. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO FOR OPPOSITION
ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. ALL RIGHT FINAL BILL ELLIS
ABOUT TWENTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
ESTIMATES ONE TIME COST OF ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM THE INSURANCE FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
IF REGULATIONS ARE NECESSARY TO
CORPORATE THESE NEW
REQUIREMENTS. ADDITIONALLY THE
PARK THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE ESTIMATES MINOR
OBSERVABLE COSTS. ALL RIGHT AND
I HEARD A MOTION BY MISTER WHAT
KOWSKI. SEEING NO OTHER HANDS
GO UP MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL IN THIS IS A TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. THE DAILY
A CLOSE. FIFTY S. RIVAL CALLING
ALL RIGHT NO. TO DO FASTER THE
SENATE FLOOR THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO I CONTINUE OUR
BATES AYE BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE IT'LL AYE
JONES I'D JONES I LEYVA HI
LEYVA HI MARKOWSKI HI CASKEY
ARE BELOW SEVEN VOTES THE BILL
HAS SEVEN VOTES AND IT IS OUT
WE WILL MOVE ON TO THE JOB
MISTER HILL. TELL MISTER WOULD.
IT WAS TOUCH AND GO ALL THE WAY.
I WE'LL- THANK THAT IS MISS
BATES WON OVER MISTER O'DONNELL
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX ON
TEMPORARY SCHOOL CLOSURE
NOTIFICATION HE'S WAY
PRESENTATION THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM IS THERE ANYBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NONE
ANYBODY ONLINE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT. ONE
ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE ONE THAT'S
QUEUED UP IT'S LINE ONE NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
TERRITORY TO KERO WE HAVE TO
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
Q. ALL RIGHTS SEE NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM IN OPPOSITION IS OR
ANY OPPOSITION IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION
ON THE LINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO FOR A POSITION. ONE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT BARBARA FINANCE TELL
US ABOUT. TWENTY ONE TWENTY
SIX. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
FOR THE FOLLOWING REASONS A
RATHER THAN CREATING ENTIRELY
NEW WEBSITE A WEB BASED
APPLICATION OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION COULD USE EXISTING
RESOURCES TO DISPLAY A
TEMPORARY. YOU RESOURCES
DESPITE TEMPORARY SCHOOL
CLOSURE INFORMATION. OF THIS
BILL CREATES COST A HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS NOT
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND. OF WHICH SIXTY
ONE THOUSAND IS ON GOING OF FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO DEVELOP
UPDATE AND MAINTAIN A WEBSITE
AND WEB BASED APPLICATION. I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT PROVIDED FOR
TWO POSITIONS FOR AN EMERGENCY
TEAM. AT THE DEPARTMENT TO
REPAIR A DISASTER PLAN AND THE
ACTIVITIES IN THIS BILL MAY BE
DUPLICATIVE OR CONFLICT WITH
THE FUTURE PLANS OF THE
EMERGENCY TEAM. WHEN IT COMES
TO MANAGING TEMPORARY SCHOOL
CLOSURES. THANK YOU FOR SEEING
NO HANDS GO UP. WITHOUT
OBJECTION TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. DURING THE
MISTRUSTING TWENTY ONE NINETY
EIGHT UNCLAIMED PROPERTY.
THERE'S NO RUSH IN THIS ROOM TO
THE MICROPHONE SO LET'S MOVE TO
TWENTY FORTY. SUPPORT I MEAN.
FOR SHE KNOW WHEN THEY'RE
ANYONE ONLINE IN SUPPORT OF
TWENTY ONE NINETY EIGHT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
ONE ZERO I DON'T REMEMBER. AND
WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. HI
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM ANYBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. NO ONE THERE
ANYBODY ONLINE OPPOSED. TO AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY EIGHT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. AS FINANCE
HAVE A FILE ON AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY EIGHT. YES MR HERE WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE- AS IT
COULD RESULT IN INDIRECT
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES
RELATING TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF ELECTRONIC FUND TRANSFER
FUNCTIONALITY- IN THESE COSTS
ARE NOT INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT. OF THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE ESTIMATES
THAT IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE NEW RESOURCES
FROM THE UNCLAIMED PROPERTY
FUND- AS FOLLOWS AND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO THREE MILLION
DOLLARS AND NINE POSITIONS. A
TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. THREE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN. TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE AND THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ON COMEY.
RIGHT SEEING NO RUSH OF HANDS
GO UP AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION. A. B. TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY THREE. ALSO BY MR
TAKING ON SHELTER CRISIS
DECORATIONS. THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORTERS OR
ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. IN
SUPPORT SAYING NO WHEN THERE IS
OR ANYONE ONLINE IN SUPPORT OF
AB. TWENTY FIVE FIFTY THREE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. FOR
SUPPORT ONE ZERO. WE DO HAVE
ONE THAT'S QUEUED UP IT'S NINE
TO THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
SEE TURN MEMBERS SUCH AS ROSS
BARKLEY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISTER BUCKLEY AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT ANY
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM ANYBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY. THERE'S NOBODY OVER
THERE ANYBODY ONLINE IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO FOR OPPOSITION ONE
ZERO. CAN WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT BERMAN FINANCE TELL
US ABOUT AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
THREE. I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
BUT WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON
THIS BILL THAT WOULD KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES
ONGOING ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS OF
SIX HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND. RELATED TO THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SEEING NO HANDS
RUSHED TO GO UP WITH COMMENTS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPEND THIS. MOVING TO THE
EVER POPULAR TRANSPORTATION
OMNIBUS BILL TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
FIVE IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE TRANSPORTATION
BILL. SEEING NO ONE ANYBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY. OH MY GOODNESS
IT'S EMPTY ANYBODY ONLINE. IN
SUPPORT OF THE TRANSPORTATION-
THE BUT THERE'S GOT. TO BE NOM
TO BUSSMANN SOMEWHERE. NO ONE
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO FOUR SUPPORT ONE ZERO.
THEN WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. OH MY
GOODNESS ALL RIGHT NO ONE'S IN
THIS ROOM IN OPPOSITION ANYBODY
IN TWENTY FORTY THAT'S SUPPOSED
TO THE TRANSPORTATION OMNIBUS
BILL. SEEING NOW ON THEIR
ANYBODY ONLINE. SOMEBODY'S GOT
TO BE ANTI TRANSPORTATION. NO
PRESS ONE THEN PROBLEM. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. HOME MY
GOODNESS SETS A RECORD ALL
RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TELL US ABOUT AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION ON THIS BILL- BUT DO
NOTE THAT THE BILL CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATE. ROAD MAINTENANCE
AND REHABILITATION ACCOUNT
INTEREST. ASSEMBLY THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION.
THESE FUNDSCURRENTLY HAVE NO
USAGE RESTRICTIONS.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL EXTENDS
THE MANDATE REQUIRING THEIR
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD TO
DEDICATE 20% OF CLEAN TRUCK
PROGRAM REVENUE. ZERO OR NEAR
ZERO EMISSION HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKS- THIS WILL RESULT IN AN
UNKNOWN AMOUNT OF FUNDS BEING
DEDICATED TO THIS PURPOSE FOR
ANOTHER YEAR. ALL RIGHTS WITH
THAT COMMENT I SEE NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY FIVE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING IMAGE CARILLO
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE CHILD
SUPPORT SUSPENSION. THERE'S NO
ONE HERE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
IT IS THERE ANYONE IN TWENTY
FORTY. IN FAVOR THERE'S NO
AMERISUR ANYONE ONLINE. IN
FAVOR OF TWENTY THREE. TWENTY
FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORT ONE ZERO. AND
WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ONE AND Q.
ANY OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM TWENTY FORTY. ONLY
GOES SO ANYBODY ONLINE. OPPOSES
RUSSIAN ONE TWINS ZERO. FOR
OPPOSITION ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHTS.
IRAN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THANK YOU- THIS BILL WILL
RESULT IN INCREASED WORKLOAD
AND COST IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE OF FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD HERE'S- TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF. CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES OF
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND.
AND A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. THANK YOU.
SEE NO COMMENTS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FIVE ABOUT A SUSPENSE.
THE MOVE ON THE AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT BY MS CARILLO ON
INTERNATIONAL MEDICAL GRADUATE
STUDIES. SEE NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM IN SUPPORT ANYBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT. SEEN
NO ONE THERE ANYBODY IN. ONLINE
IN SUPPORT OF. TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT ONE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT OPPOSITION. NO ONE'S IN
THIS ROOM ANYBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY WAIT THAT'S CASPER IN THE
CORNER I THINK NO THAT'S WE
MISSED THEM THERE'S NOBODY IN A
IN TWENTY FORTY LET'S GO ONLINE
FOR OPPOSITION TO TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT ONLY A COUPLE OF
YOU GOT THAT WERE WAITING. ON
THE ON. I THOUGHT I STARTED AS
ONE THEN ZERO TO OPPOSE ONE
ZERO. WHO YOU GONNA CALL. OKAY.
WE HAVE NO KNOWN IN CUBA NO
OPPOSITION AND SO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE CAN SEE YOU. THANK
YOU THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS ESTIMATES ONE TIME
CONTRACT COSTS IN THE RANGE OF
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND TO FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS-
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD NOTE THAT
THE MEDICAL BOARD'S FUND HAS A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT. CURRENTLY
REQUIRES HE INCREASES TO
SUPPORT EXISTING COSTS I WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT THIS STUDY
REQUIRED BY THIS BILL AND MAY
NOT BE INAPPROPRIATE USE OF FEE
REVENUES PAID BY EXISTING
LICENSEES. FINALLY IT'S UNCLEAR
IF THE BILLS ONE YEAR TIME
FRAME PROVIDE SUFFICIENT TIME
TO ESTABLISH THE CONTRACT TO
CONDUCT THE STUDY AND PREPARE
THE REPORT. ALL RIGHT SEE NOTE
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING TO
MISTER BIGELOW AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY ON PEACE OFFICER DEPUTY
SHERIFFS. AND THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT ANYBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY UP CASPER
LEFT US- SO LET'S GO TO ONLINE
ANYBODY WANTED SHARE SUPPORT
FOR TWENTY THREE FORTY. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
ONE ZERO. THEN WE HAVE NO ONE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY HERE IN THE
OPPOSED TO TWENTY THREE FORTY
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY. NOBODY
THERE ANYBODY ONLINE OPPOSED AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY BY MR
BIGELOW. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NO WARNING TO. ALL
RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- THIS
BILL COULD RESULT IN MINOR-
ANSWERABLE COSTS TO POST TO THE
EXTENT THAT DEPUTY SHERIFFS IN
THE COUNTY SPECIFIED BY THE
BILL WOULD REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
MANDATED INTRODUCTORY
INTERESTED FIREARMS TRAINING.
ONLY BECAUSE EXISTING LAW
PROVIDES CERTAIN PROCEDURAL
RIGHTS FOR PEACE OFFICERS
RELATING TO INVESTIGATIONS AND
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS. A
PROVISION OF THOSE RIGHTS COULD
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT
REIMBURSABLE COSTS. TO THE
STATE. THANK YOU SEE NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING TO MISTER
GRAYSON AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY ON
AIR AMBULANCE SERVICES
EMERGENCY BILL. I SEE NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT I SEE
ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY I'D BE
SHOCKED. NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
ANYBODY ONLINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT ONE
ZERO. OR SECOND OR BOARD ALL.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
HERE ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
NOBODY THERE ANYBODY ONLINE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOUR OPPOSITION. ONE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO ONE TO END
UP AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. YES WE'RE
NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE I WOULD
NOTE THAT WOULD HAVE A POSITIVE
FISCAL IMPACT OF APPROXIMATELY
ONE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
TO THE GENERAL FUND OVER THE
ONE YEAR PERIOD DO THE
CONTINUATION OF THE 20% GENERAL
FUND OFFSET THAT REFUSING
MEDICAL AIR TRANSPORTATION AND
CHILDREN'S COVERAGE FUND. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR THAT SEEING
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING TO AB TWENTY
FIVE. NINETY TWO. BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
ON REDUCTION OF HUMAN REMAINS.
AND THE DISPOSITION OF REDUCED
HUMAN REMAINS- THERE'S NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT ANYBODY
IN TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT
ANYBODY ONLINE IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSE ANYBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED. ANYBODY
ONLINE OPPOSE. AND PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION ONE
ZERO. ON ONE OF THE TO START.
AND WE HAVE KNOWING QUEUING UP
ALL RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HEREON. FILE ON THIS MISSION NO
FILE OKAY NO FINAL COMMENTS
THAT MEANS AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY TWO GOES TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION. MOVING THE
AB TWENTY SIX OH SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SERVAN TASTES ON
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SUPERVISED
RELEASE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM IN SUPPORT ANYBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. IN SUPPORT.
ANYBODY ONLINE IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT. ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE
KNOWN IN Q. ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY HERE
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED
NOBODY THERE ANYBODY ONLINE
OPPOSED. PLEASE PRESS ONE
MILLION ZERO FOR OPPOSITION.
ONE ZERO. CAN WE HAVE KNOWN IN
Q. ALL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. IN TWENTY ELEVEN THE
STATE REALIGNED RESPONSIBILITY
FOR CERTAIN TYPES OF COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION INCLUDING POST
RELEASE COMMUNITY SUPERVISION-
AND MANDATORY SUPERVISION TO
COUNTIES. TO THE EXTENT THE
COUNTIES ARE NOT CURRENTLY
UPDATING CLASS AT LEAST EVERY
TEN DAYS A SPECIFIED IN THIS
BILL AND FUNDING INCLUDED IN
THE BUDGET ACT ISN'T SUFFICIENT
FOR COUNTIES TO UPDATE AS
REQUIRED OF THE COUNT IS NOT BE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THE
INCREASED LEVEL OF SERVICE
RESEARCH PROPOSITION THIRTY.
ADDITIONALLY WOULD NOTE THAT
THE BILL MAY IMPOSE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE BY
REQUIRING LOCAL AGENCIES TO
UPDATE CLASS FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
SENTENCED DIRECTLY TO FORMAL
PROBATION FROM THE COURTS AS
THIS WOULD LIKELY FALL NOT FALL
UNDER PROPOSITION THIRTY
PROCESS. ALL RIGHT SEEING OTHER
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB
TWENTY SIX OH SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. WHICH MEANS WE ARE ON
MY LAST PAGE. MR GABRIEL AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN FIREARMS
GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDERS. THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM IN SUPPORT ANYBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT.
ANYBODY ONLINE IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT ONE ZERO. WHEN WE HAVE
KNOWING QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHTS
TO ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION IN
THIS ROOM KNOW ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION IN TWENTY FORTY NOW
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION ONE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE KNOWN IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT IS THERE
FILE. YES MISTER CHAIR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE INDICATES
COST A FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND FIVE THOUSAND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER FOR THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL. SEEING
NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE MISTER
STONE. ON CANNABIS THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT
ANYBODY IN. TWENTY TO FORTY IN
SUPPORT ANYBODY KNOW ANYBODY
ONLINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. ONE ZERO.
LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE ONE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT. THEY'RE
GETTING THEIR LINE NUMBER NOW
BEAR WITH ME. BERMAN BEEN OPEN
THE LINE TO FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS ANNE
FRANCO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THE ROOM HERE ANYBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. ANYBODY ONLINE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
PARTMINER FINANCE. THANK YOU
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS STATES THERE ARE
CURRENTLY NO STANDARDIZED
TESTING METHODOLOGIES FOR
CANNABIS OR CANNABIS PRODUCTS
PRODUCTS IN THE US THEREFORE
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE BUREAU
TO DEVELOP STANDARDS FROM THE
GROUND UP WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES. ANOTHER
WOULD KNOW THE DEPARTMENT-
INDICATES THAT DUE TO THE BEER
OF CANNABIS CONTROL RECEIVING
RESOURCES FOR REFERENCE
LABORATORY BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE FISCAL
IMPACT OF THIS BILL IS
ANTICIPATED TO BE MINOR WITHIN
EXIST. IT ACT INCLUDED THREE
POINT MILLION DOLLARS CANNABIS
CONTROL FUND WHICH TWO POINT
THREE MILLION IS ONE TIME. AND
ONE POINT ONE MILLION IS ON
GOING TO CONTRACT FOR REFERENCE
LABORATORY. FINALLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE INDICATES A MINOR
IMPACT ON THE TRACK AND TRACE
SYSTEM. THANK YOU FOR THAT
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION. TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ON TO TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE
MY MISSION IS AREA IN. THE
RICHARD PAUL. HEYMAN
PARKINSON'S DISEASE PROGRAM
THERE'S NO ONE IN THE ROOM AND
SUPPORT ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
IN SUPPORT. ANYBODY ONLINE IN
SUPPORT. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT ONE ZERO. AND
WE HAVE KNOWN IN CUBA TO START.
NO ONE IN Q. ANY OPPOSITION NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM ANYBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY. ANYBODY ONLINE
OPPOSED. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOR OPPOSITION ONE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE KNOWN IN Q.
ALL RIGHT BERMAN FINANCE. YES
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ESTIMATES COST OF FOUR HUNDRED
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND REALLY
THEREAFTER TO TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX OR PROCESS THE
TWO MILLION DOLLARS OVER FIVE
YEARS THANK YOU THEY GIVE SAFE
NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WILL GO TO SUSPEND. MOVING ON
TO AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN.
MR CHIU ON FIREARMS ON SAVE
HAND GUNS AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM ANYBODY IN. ROOM TWENTY
FORTY ANYBODY ONLINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM ANYBODY IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN. ANYBODY ONLINE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF
YOU WISH TO OPPOSE. ONE ZERO.
WE DO HAVE A FEW THAT HAVE
QUEUED UP ONE MOMENT WHEN THEY
GETS IN LINE NUMBERS. FIRST
GOING ONLINE. TO TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN IS CARLENE ELLIS. I AM
A MEMBER OF THE SOUTH
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION THE NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION THE
INTERNATIONAL DEFENSIVE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION SACRAMENTO
DEFENSIVE PISTOL SHOOTERS AND
THE FOCAL SHOOTING CLUB AND AN
AVID RECREATIONAL INCOME
COMPETITIVE SHOOTER IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
STRONGLY OPPOSE. AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
OUR THANKS FOR GOING TO GO TO
LINE ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
THIS IS REALLY GOOD FOR THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION. STRONG OPPOSITION
MEASURE THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE
GONNA GO TO LINE TWO SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY
NAME IS MICHAEL AND THEN WITH
THE NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION OR TRADE ASSOCIATION
FOR AMERICA'S FIREARMS AND
AMMUNITION MANUFACTURERS WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I'M NOT TRYING TO GO TO LINE
TWO TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THANK YOU MY NAME'S
DURING BAD WELL I AM A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION IN THE SOUTH
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER IN A MEMBER
GUNNERS CAL CALIFORNIA MEMBER I
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE
ONE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH LIKE
MANY FOR THE RECORD DANRY WITH
THE NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU. AND OUR FINAL
IN Q. COMES FROM LINE ONE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AS CHAIR THE
SYSTEMIC MAN ON THE CHAIR OF
THE SOUTH SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION. AN NRA MEMBER IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. MR HERE
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COSTS IN THE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS-
GENERAL FUND AND SPECIAL FUNDS
FROM THE REGULATIONS AND
POTENTIALLY TO UPDATE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS
AND PROVIDE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SPORT ARE THESE
COSTS COULD BE GREATER-
DEPENDING ON THE LEVEL OF DATA
REQUESTS RESULTING FROM THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SEE NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY SEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB THIRTY FORTY. LOCAL
PLANNING REGIONAL HOUSING.
NEEDS ASSESSMENT. THERE'S NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
ANYBODY ONLINE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOUR SUPPORT.
ONE ZERO. WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
QUEUEING UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
FIRST RUNNING ON THE LINE OF
TWO FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SURE THIS IS
BOB NAIL REPRESENTING KEELS TED
IN COMPANY AND ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS STRONGLY SUPPORTING
CALIFORNIA YIMBY WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL BECAUSE INCENTIVIZING
HOUSING IS GOOD FISCAL POLICY
FOR THE STATE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
SOME IN OPPOSITION TO A THIRTY
FOUR YEAR. I DON'T KNOW FROM
THE SEQUENCE OR NOT- THIS IS
RAY LAURA WITH SIXTY NINE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BOTH. AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q. ALL
RIGHT DID WE DO OPPOSITION NO.
SO ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM AS
OPPOSED NOW ANYBODY TWENTY
FORTY OPPOSED NOW ANYBODY
ONLINE OTHER THAN THAT ONE
PERSON OUT ORDER. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO TO OPPOSE. ONE
ZERO. WE DO HAVE A FEW QUEUING
UP WILL FIRST GO TO THE LINE
ONE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN YES MY NAME
IS HOLLY CALIFORNIA REJECTED
PROFESSIONALLY ENGINEERED THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THIS BILL
CREATES A SPECIAL CATEGORY FOR
FOREIGN A LOT ON MY CITY HAS A
LOT OF TO ONE OF ARTS AND THREE
ON A LOT. THAT SERVE THE SAME
PURPOSE AND THIS ISN'T ANOTHER
UNNECESSARY PHYSICAL
COMPLICATION IN WRITING THE
HOUSING ELEMENT SO I TOLD. THE
FORTY THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE TWO TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS TESS TAYLOR IN THE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM OF THE WEST
TO LEGALLY REGISTERED RESIDENTS
ASSOCIATION IN LOS ANGELES
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO AB THIRTY
FORTY THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE ONE EIGHTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
MEAN BROKEN COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION I ALSO TRIED
TO CALL FOR TO OPPOSE AB SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE BUT WAS NOT
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES
COST OF ONE HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
IN THE FIRST YEAR AND A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND ONGOING TO
DEVELOP GUIDANCE TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
PUBLISHES INFORMATION ONLINE.
ANY REQUEST FOR RESOURCES ARE
SUBJECT TO REVIEW AND APPROVAL
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS. C.
NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THIRTY FORTY WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. GOING TO AB
THIRTY TO SIXTY NINE STATE
LEVEL AGENCY HOMELESS PLAN.
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
NO ANYBODY ONLINE IN SUPPORT OF
AB. THIRTY TO SIXTY NINE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. ONE ZERO. I DO HAVE
ONE IN IN Q. HERE IT'S LINE TO
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
PROSPECT WE ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO MAYOR DARRELL
STEINBERG IN SUPPORT. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSE ANYBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY. OPPOSED ANYBODY
ONLINE OPPOSE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO FOR OPPOSITION ONE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
YOU THIS BILLS REQUIREMENTS ON
STATE AND LOCAL ENTITIES COULD
RESULT IN AN UNKNOWN BUT
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COSTS
A POTENTIALLY IN THE HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS TO LOW BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ANNUALLY IF THE
COMMISSION ON STATE MANDATES
FINES AT THE ASSOCIATED COSTS
INCURRED BY CITIES AND COUNTIES
TO IMPLEMENT THE LOCAL PLANS TO
MEET THE BENCHMARK GOALS.
REDUCING THE HOMELESS.
POPULATIONS ARE STATE MANDATED
AND THEREFORE REIMBURSABLE
ADDITIONALLY THE BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES AND HOUSING
AGENCY ESTIMATES GENERAL FUND
COSTS OF ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE
FIRST YEAR AND A AND ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THE SECOND YEAR.
FINALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES. GENERAL
FUND COSTS OF TWO POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE FIRST
YEAR. AND TWO MILLION DOLLARS
ON GOING. NEEDED TO IMPLEMENT
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB THIRTY TO
SIXTY NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WE WILL MOVE ON TO MISTER JONES
SAWYER A. B. THIRTY FORTY
THREE. CORRECTIONS CONFIDENTIAL
CALLS ANYONE IN THIS ROOM KNOWS
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY. NO
ANYBODY ONLINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY FORTY THREE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME FOR SUPPORT. ONE ZERO.
THEN WE HAVE KNOWN IN Q. ALL
RIGHT ANY OPPOSITION THE THIRTY
FORTY THREE NO ONE HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY NO ONLINE
OPPOSITION TO THIRTY FORTY
THREE. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO TO OPPOSE. ONE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE KNOWN IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT BERMAN
FINANCE. NEVER HEARD OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION-
INDICATES COST AND MORE IN THIS
BILL ARE UNKNOWN IT COULD RANGE
FROM MINOR OBSERVABLE TO
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY
DEPENDING ON THE SUBSEQUENT
YOUR CHANGES RESULTING FROM THE
STILL. SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB THIRTY
FORTY THREE. WE'RE GOING TO
SUSPENSE FOR MOVING ON AB
THIRTY TWO SEVENTY SEVEN WHICH
IS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AND MISSILE ARE YOU ARE
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF. MR
JONES SAWYER I UNDERSTAND THAT
I AM PLEASE TELLUS ABOUT AB
THIRTY TWO SEVENTY SEVEN GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
LOVELY TO SEE ALL OF YOU. I
COME BEFORE YOU TO RESENT AB
THIRTY TWO SEVENTY SEVEN FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOINT COUNCIL
HERE A BILL THAT WILL PROVIDE
SOME RELIEF FOR LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS FACING PARKING
FINES. THIS BILL WILL EASE THE
ECONOMIC BURDEN OF HIGHER
PARKING DEBT BY INCREASING
ACCESS TO PAYMENT PLANS WHICH
IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT AS WE
DEAL WITH THE ECONOMIC FALLOUT
OF COVERT. THIS BILL WILL OFFER
IMPORTANT ECONOMIC RELIEF WHILE
PROVIDING CITIES A FAIR AND
EQUITABLE WAY TO COLLECT
REVENUE THAT INDIVIDUALS
OTHERWISE WOULD BE UNABLE TO
PAY. AS THE APPROPRIATIONS
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THIS BILL
HAS ONLY MINOR REDUCTIONS IN
STATE AND LOCAL PARKING
CITATION REVENUE WHICH WILL BE
MITIGATED PARTIALLY BY SOME
REVENUE GAINS FOR PAYMENTS ON
DEBT. THAT MAY NOT OTHERWISE
HAVE BEEN PAID. ON THE PHONE TO
TESTIFY IS TRACY COUPLE GUCCI
FROM THE LOS ANGELES HOMELESS
SERVICES AUTHORITY WHO ARE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL I MEMBERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. TRACY IF YOU'RE THERE GO
AHEAD LIKE. OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ON THE ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TWO SEVENTY SEVEN MY
NAME IS TRACY HOW EUGENE AND
LET THE LOS ANGELES HOMELESS
SERVICES AUTHORITY LOS
ANGELENOS WRITER OF PUBLIC
SERVICES THE LOS ANGELES
CONVENE THE CARE IN HERE TODAY
AT THE- COUNTER OF THE SELF AB
THIRTY TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
PROVIDE LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING THE MANY WHO RELY ON
THEIR VEHICLES FOR SHELTER. THE
MORE FLEXIBLE PATHWAY TO PASS
THEIR PARKING THAT AND MAINTAIN
THEIR VEHICLES REDUCING
BARRIERS TO COMPLETING
ALTERNATE PAYMENT PLAN THE
CHANGES PROPOSED IN THE BILL
WILL HELP MORE RESIDENTS ACCESS
INTO EXACTLY COMPLETE THEIR
PAYMENT PLANS INTERNET WITHIN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COVERING
REVENUE THAT THEY MAY NOT
OTHERWISE BEEN PAID WITHOUT THE
ADDED FLEXIBILITY FOR THESE
REASONS YOU'RE EFFECTIVELY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT. FOR THE
BILL THANK YOU. TO THERE'S NO
ELSE IN THIS ROOM IN. OF IN TO
FORTY SOME. ANYONE ELSE CUED UP
ONLINE IN SUPPORT OF THIRTY TO
SEVENTY SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO FOUR SUPPORT ONE
EIGHT ZERO. AND WE HAVE KNOWN
IN Q. I NOT POSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSE
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED
ANYBODY ONLINE OPPOSED. AND
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION ONE ZERO. THEN WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. R. I.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR WERE NEUTRAL
ON THIS MEASURE THE DEPARTMENT
OF MOTOR VEHICLES DOESN'T
ANTICIPATED FISCAL IMPACT. AS
ALL THE ACTIVITIES ARE
PERFORMED BY LOCAL PARKING
CONTROL AGENCIES PARTY
INFORMATION BEING TRANSMITTED
TO DMV. ALL RIGHT MS LEVEL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THE
CLASS FOR AN AYE VOTE ALL RIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO DO PASSED TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR WE HAVE A
MOTION. IT IS. WE HAVE A MOTION
HELLO THEY ARE RIGHT BRADFORD
BEACH ALL. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A
MOTION PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEASURES ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
TWO SEVEN SEVEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO FIVE PORTANTINO I
BATES AYE FADES AYE BRADFORD.
ALL RIGHT BRADFORD HI HILL HILL
BY JONES. JONES FIVE LEYVA AYE
LEYVA BY RECOUNTS SKI HI CASKEY
ARE. SEVEN WAS MISTER BILL AS
SEVEN VOTES AND IS OUT WE HAVE
FOUR TO GO TEAM AB THIRTY FIFTY
THREE BY MR DAILY ON LABOR
COMMISSIONER UNPAID WAGE CLAIMS
IS THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
KNOWS OR ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY
NOW IS THERE ANYONE ONLINE WHO
WANTS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF
AB THIRTY FIFTY THREE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
ONE ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE THAT
IS QUEUED UP ARE OVER THERE GET
IN THEIR LINE NUMBER ONE MOMENT.
AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE TWO
OH ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS
PROCEEDING- CALLING FROM
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF. THIS BILL AND ALSO WANTED
TO CALL HOME- AS
REPRESENTATIVES FOR AMERICAN
DESCENDANTS OF SLAVERY THE
OPENING CHAPTER IN THE END OF
LACI PETE. IN SUPPORT OF- AB.
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q.
ALL RIGHT ANY OPPOSITION TO
THIRTY FIFTY THREE THERE'S NO
ONE HERE ANYBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY. NO ONE THERE ANYBODY
ONLINE OPPOSED. PLEASE PRESS
ONE MIN ZERO FOR OPPOSITION.
ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE KNOWN IN
Q. ALL RIGHTS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS ESTIMATES
COST OF FIFTEEN POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS INITIALLY AND
FOURTEEN POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING FROM THAT
LABOR ENFORCEMENT AND
COMPLIANCE FUND THIS ESTIMATE
INCLUDES THREE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS TO DEVELOP AND
MAINTAIN THE ONLINE SYSTEM OF
THE REMAINING COSTS ARE FOR
STAFF RESOURCES THANK YOU THANK
YOU SINGLE OUT. MISTER WHITE
CASKEY. I A QUESTION FOR
FINANCE IT SEEMS UNBELIEVABLE
FOR ME THAT THESE WERE UNPAID
WAGE CLAIMS. IN THE INDICATE
THAT THE COULD COST US TEN
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO PAY
THE WAGES TO THESE PEOPLE WHO
DIDN'T GET PAID BY THEM. BUT
IT'S GOING TO COST THE
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS FIFTEEN
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS TO
SET UP THE PORTAL IN ORDER TO
PAY TEN MILLION DOLLARS WITH
THE CLAIMS. I FIND IT
INCREDIBLE MISTER CHAIR THAT
YOU PAY FIFTEEN MILLION
SEXUALLY PALE PINK WAGES THE
PEOPLE DIDN'T GET OF TEN
MILLION IS THERE SOME REASON
FOR THAT. THAT I'M MISSING.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR THE
QUESTION- SO THE FIFTEEN POINT
SIX IS A COMBINATION OF UP TO
COST- THREE POINT THREE MILLION
IS ACTUALLY TO DEVELOP AND-
DEVELOP AND MAINTAIN THE SYSTEM
AND THE REMAINING ACOSTA
ACTUALLY FOR STAFF RESOURCES.
THAT WOULD BE TO PROCESS THE
ANTICIPATED INCREASE IN. IN IN
CLAIMS- YES IN THE IN THE
ADDITIONAL WHICH CLAIMS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT- SEVEN
THIS ESTIMATE IS BASED IN PART
ON IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
DEPARTMENT ACTUALLY DID UP THE
PILOT IN ONLINE- CLAIM FILING
SYSTEM FOR ONE MONTH. ON
EXPERIENCED A 47% INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF WAGE CLAIMS
FILED. SO THE ESTIMATE IS BASED
ON AN ASSUMPTION THAT WITH AN
ONLINE SYSTEM THERE WOULD BE
ADDITIONAL ADDITIONAL CLAIMS
FILED. WE WILL BE WORKING
MISTER MISTER CHAIR I CAN I GET
THAT THREE POINT THREE MILLION
TO SET IT UP BUT WE'RE STILL AT
THE END OF THE DAY WE'RE WE'RE
SPENDING. TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS AND INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS DEPARTMENT TO PAY TEN
MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF WITH
THE FOUR AGES THAT THESE I GET
THE PEOPLE DIDN'T GET THE WAGES
I WOULD BEG. THE DEPARTMENT TO.
SO HOW DO A JOB YOU CAN'T YOUR
PAIN MORE THAN DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR FOR PEOPLE WHO LOST
THEIR WAGES IT JUST SEEMS. NUTS
IT'S LIKE A PERSON IN A CUBICLE
WITH A CHECK FOR COULD DO IT A
LOT CHEAPER TO SEE TO IT I JUST
WANT A FLAG THAT FOR THE
COMMUNITY. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
FOR THOSE VERY GOOD COMMENTS-
OUTSIDE OF THAT WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THIRTY FIFTY THREE
WILL GO TO SUSPEND US. AB
THIRTY FIFTY SIX BY MS GONZALEZ
WAREHOUSE DISTRIBUTION CENTERS
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
ANYBODY ONLINE FIFTEEN FROM.
THE THAT THE- PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT.
ONE ZERO. DOZENS AND WE HAVE
KNOWN IN CUBA ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THE ROOM ANYBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY. NO ONE'S THERE ANYBODY
ONLINE IN OPPOSITION. TO THIRTY
FIFTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO TO OPPOSE ONE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE KNOWN IN Q. ALL
RIGHT FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS
DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT ESTIMATES COSTS OF
THREE HUNDRED FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THE FIRST YEAR AND
TWO HUNDRED NINETY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING FROM THE LABOR
ENFORCEMENT AND COMPLIANCE FUND
A TO PROMULGATE RAGS AND TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT SIGNAL
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB
THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. BARLASTON BILL. AB
THREE OH NINE NINE BY MISTER
RAMOS AND APARTMENT A JUSTICE
LAW ENFORCEMENT'S ASSISTANCE
WITH TRIBAL ISSUES. NO ONE IN
THE ROOM IN SUPPORT. NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY AND SUPPORT
ANYBODY ONLINE IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT ONE ZERO. DO I MISS ONE
YEAH INITIALISM I'M SORRY I GOT
CONFUSED I WILL GO BACK TO THAT
ONE BUT LET'S FINISH RAMOS ANY
OPPOSITION. ANYBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY OPPOSED. ANYBODY ONLINE
OPPOSED. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO FOUR OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT GIVE US A REPORT ON AB
THREE OH NINE NINE. MISTER
CHAIR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ESTIMATES A COST OF
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. APPROXIMATELY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER TO CONDUCT OUTREACH
ACTIVITIES A PRELIMINARY
TRAININGS RESEARCH AND COMPILE.
INFORMATION FOR THE REQUIRED
STUDY AND COLLABORATE WITH
OTHER DEPARTMENTAL AND TRAVEL
STAKEHOLDERS. I WOULD NOTE THAT
ANY REQUEST RESOURCES WOULD BE
EVALUATED TO THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS. ALL RIGHT SEEING NO
OBJECTION AB THREE OH NINE NINE
WILL GO TO SUSPEND SO I MIXED
UP THREE OH FIVE SIX AND THREE
OH SEVEN FIVE. WHICH ONE THAT I
ANNOUNCE IT THREE OH FIVE SIX.
SO WE DID THE REPORT FROM
FINANCE ON THREE OH FIVE SIX SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB THREE OH
FIVE SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
AND THEN WILL RE OPEN. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THREE OH SEVEN FIVE
IS OR ANYONE HERE. KNOW ANYBODY
IN. THE ROOM NOW- ANYBODY
ONLINE. FOR THREE OH SEVEN
FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION
THREE OH SEVEN FIVE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE IN TWENTY FORTY
NOBODY THERE ANYBODY ONLINE YOU
KNOW OPPOSED. TO THREE OH SEVEN
FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO TO OPPOSE ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
FORMER FINANCE TELL US ABOUT
THREE OH SEVEN FIVE. SECRETARY
ST ESTIMATES THIS BILL WILL
RESULT IN GENERAL FUND COSTS
TOTALING FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS INITIALLY AND
SEVENTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON GOING TO PROVIDE OUTREACH TO
BUSINESSES CHANGE FORMS WEBSITE
IMPROVEMENTS AND TO TRAIN
STAFF. AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS REPORTS ON
MINOR OBSERVABLE COSTS
SIMILARLY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. MINORS COSTS
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT ANY
COMMENTS NO WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB THREE OH SEVEN FIVE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE AND I BELIEVE
THAT'S EVERYTHING RIGHT. THANK
YOU EVERYBODY WE GOT A LOT MORE
TO GO AND THERE'S MORE FOR ME
TO ANNOUNCE AT THE END HOLD ON
LET ME MAKE SURE THAT I GET ALL
OF OUR- WE'VE NOTHING'S ON CALL.
SURE EVERYTHING IS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH SO THAT
CONCLUDES OUR HEARING FOR TODAY
I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY YOU'RE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR ANY
REASON PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE-
WANT TO. INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY
IN THE OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORDS. THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK EVERYONE
FOR THEIR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION. WE HAVE NOW
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA AND WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY
IN THIS MEETING IS CHURCH.